С вами Вектор Т13. И в этот замечательный субботний вечер мы можем начать наш вебинар.
Сегодняшняя тема будет посвящена геолокации.
Основным, десяти основным методикам, которые применяются для определения геолокации пользователя.
Буквально в течение одной минуты сейчас мы настроим звук и наш вебинар начнется.
Итак, звук проверен, все окей. Итак, всех приветствую, всех приветствую, с вами Вектор Т13.
Итак, геолокация. Невероятно важный инструмент в текущее время.
Еще буквально лет пять назад можно было его полностью игнорировать, поскольку геолокация была построена всего-навсего на определении IP-адреса.
Но сейчас времена изменились и чем больше наш компьютер, благодаря браузерам,
интегрировался в геолокацию, тем больше мы можем его использовать.
И чем больше он интегрируется во всемирную сеть, тем больше нам необходимо обезопасить себя от определения нашей реальной геолокации.
Как для приватности, анонимности, так, возможно, для получения каких-то бонусов и преференций от некоторых сервисов.
Но прежде чем мы начнем наш сегодняшний вебинар, я хотел бы рассказать о небольших новостях.
Как по традиции, делаю это в начале каждого вебинара.
Итак, первая наша замечательная новость.
Это внедрение нового телеграм-бота.
Точнее, первого телеграм-бота.
Множество жалоб я получаю на работу саппортов, что саппорты очень долго отвечают на вопросы пользователей и так далее.
Но, заходя в аккаунты саппортов, я просматриваю, все-таки выполняю определенный контроль качества и проверяю, о чем же пишут люди.
И я вам могу так сказать, ну, сложно, конечно, я не проводил в процентном соотношении, могу примерно прикинуть, где-то 85-90% это вопросы технического характера.
При этом вопросы технического характера невероятно просты.
Такое ощущение, что люди уже перестали понимать, как пользоваться компьютером, и иногда, ну, просто, скажем так, вопросы, как установить софт, ну, это уже чересчур, согласитесь.
Ну, а также, конечно же, Windows 11 принес нам довольно большое количество новых интересных функций, которые внедрены, по-моему, только лишь для того, чтобы нашу жизнь сделать хуже.
Поэтому, для того, чтобы снять нагрузку с саппортов, а также предоставить качественный уровень сервиса, я сделал телеграм-бота.
Ну, конечно же, для вас это не будет, наверное, чем-то удивительным, сейчас ботов очень много, но этот бот непростой.
Я натренировал этого бота как телеграм, как техподдержку и скормил ему всю доступную базу данных по операционным системам Windows 10, Windows 11, всю информацию по их API, полностью весь форум, посвященный VirtualBox и даже VMware, поскольку в некоторых случаях ошибки могут быть смежные.
А также, дополнительно, около 100.
Около сотни, вдумайтесь, форумов, на которых люди делятся различного рода ошибками или же какими-то твиками.
Короче, форумы компьютерных ботаников.
Эти форумы, они позволят ориентироваться боту и помогать ему в решении ваших вопросов.
Запуск бота мы планируем осуществить на следующей неделе.
Так что вы сможете его...
Вы сможете его...
Попробовать.
И это бот чисто технической поддержки.
У вас возникла ошибка?
Отправляйте боту скриншот.
У вас какая-то проблема?
Что-то не запускается?
Что-то вы не знаете?
Отправляйте боту сообщение.
Он поможет вам в решении всех ваших вопросов технического характера.
Повторюсь.
Это позволит сделать наш сервис техподдержки намного лучше и намного качественнее.
Так что, надеюсь, вам понравится.
Но, а поскольку мы заговорили о саппортах...
Рада вернуться к нашим физическим, живым людям, которых я безумно люблю.
294 заявки я получил на должность в конкурсе саппорта, который проводился неделю назад.
Это действительно большое количество.
Очень большое.
Я не ожидал, что я получу столько заявок.
Но, к сожалению, могу сказать так, что в некоторых случаях люди были...
Были слишком далеки от того понимания, что должен из себя представлять агент технической поддержки.
Поэтому, к сожалению, всего-навсего 12 человек были отобраны для участия во втором туре.
Всех, конечно же, я благодарю и советую не расстраиваться.
А почему, скажу немного дальше.
Касаемо этих 12 людей, которых я выделил из всего остального количества.
Выражаю вам отдельную благодарность за то, что вы приняли участие в конкурсе.
И хотел сказать следующее.
Завтра вы получите небольшую инструкцию по второму тесту.
Если... Я надеюсь, что этот тест будет финальным.
Но, опять же, если пройдут все 12 человек, тогда придется устроить еще и третий тур, к сожалению.
Но, тем не менее, я считаю, что второго тура будет вполне достаточно для того, чтобы мы определились...
...с саппортами в количестве от 1 до 3 человек.
Более 3 человек нам на текущий момент нет необходимости набирать именно технических саппортов.
Ну, так что могу пожелать всем удачи.
И завтра вы получите в личку от меня инструкции список всех пользователей, которые прошли во второй тур, опубликован на канале VectorT13.
Идем дальше.
Почему не стоит расстраиваться тем людям, которые...
...не попали в данный список или не прошли тест?
Дело в том, что наша компания, компания VectorT13 Technologies в 2026 году, прекрасном наступившем году, нацелена на очень серьезное расширение во всех областях, в которых мы работаем.
И, в частности, даже если вы не имеете технических знаний, но, например, имеете знания в банковской сфере,
понимаете, что такое ответы кодов операций,
умеете свои какие-то наработки в области кредитных карт,
да черт возьми, даже если вы предыдущий, как-то, может быть, в далеком прошлом или в далеком будущем,
в своих фантазиях вы являетесь кардером,
то я думаю, что следующий конкурс будет вам по плечу, и вам он понравится.
Потому что нам также нужны будут люди, которые разбираются изнутри, во всех тонкостях,
финансовой сферы совершения интернет-платежей.
Мы, расширяя наш сервис банковских карт, напоминаю, что для тех, кто будет смотреть этот вебинар и не знаком с моими сервисами,
у нас есть сервис по анонимным банковским картам.
Вы можете создавать неограниченное количество банковских карт, хоть по новой карте для каждой транзакции.
При этом всем у нас большое количество бинов и большое количество стран.
Пополнять данные карты вы сможете с помощью криптовалют,
и я настолько уверен в вашей добропорядочности, что не буду задавать вам лишних вопросов.
Соответственно, возвращаемся теперь к должности саппорта.
Думаю, что к концу февраля будет объявлен конкурс на саппорта в финансовой сфере.
И нам необходим будет человек, пока что один, который очень хорошо разбирается в интернет-платежах.
Так что рекомендую поучаствовать.
О начале конкурса вы узнаете на моем телеграм-канале.
Ну и к другим новостям.
12 февраля пройдет еще один вебинар.
Точнее, это ближайший наш вебинар.
В этом вебинаре я хотел бы раскрыть одну очень важную тему.
В комментариях под предыдущим видео
один человек высказался.
Нахера вот эти вот все нормы нужны?
Можно же просто установить кубис, поставить туда тор и все, короче, ты аноним.
Ну, действительно, может быть, человек этот прав, а может быть, он в корне не прав.
Давайте разберемся.
Потому что, действительно, в головах многих людей существует такая вещь,
что, например, установил Tails себе и все у тебя хорошо,
потому что Snowden рекламировал.
Установил в Hunix и у тебя все хорошо, потому что Vector его 10 лет назад рекламировал.
Установил кубис, нахера, непонятно.
Но тоже, вроде бы, какой-то CoolHatsker стал.
Может быть, тоже кто-нибудь рекламировал данную систему.
Поэтому 12 числа приглашаю всех на свой открытый вебинар.
И мы разберем, действительно ли данные системы являются такими анонимными и безопасными
с учетом текущего вебинара.
С учетом текущего времени, а именно 2026 года.
Идем дальше.
Осталось совсем немного новостей, и мы начнем нашу основную тему.
Antidetect Type 9.
Я бесконечно горд выпуском данного программного обеспечения,
данного вида персональной версии.
Уделю буквально несколько минут.
Далее я расскажу о том, что анонимный продукт является, по сути, действительно революционным.
Я объясню, почему.
Потому что некоторые методики определения геолокации, которые мы сегодня с вами как раз разберем,
они были недостижимы для правильного изменения до последнего времени.
И благодаря внедрению революционной системы эмуляции Wi-Fi сетей,
как вы видите на своих экранах,
вы, а пользователей Antidetect Type 9 уже более 300 человек,
из которых 250, плюс-минус 5 человек, около 250 человек,
принимали участие в недавней акции.
Так вот, у вас будет возможность проверить эту систему на практике.
Позволяет данная система эмулировать 20 окружающих Wi-Fi сетей,
включая полностью все необходимые параметры,
а также, что самое главное, она позволяет добавлять шумы и вариативности.
То есть сила сигнала постоянно изменяется.
Постоянно появляются скрытые сети.
Некоторые сети отпадают, другие появляются.
Иными словами, сделана максимальная реалистичная эмуляция окружающих сетей.
На первое время Wi-Fi сети необходимо будет выставлять вручную.
Но буквально в следующем обновлении мы уже сделали определенный формат,
когда вы просто выставляете свою геолокацию при создании виртуальной машины,
а дальше ставите всего один чекбокс.
И благодаря внешним API происходит автоматическая подстановка окружающих Wi-Fi сетей под ваш чекбокс.
Но не будем сейчас говорить об этом.
Когда вы получите на руки свой софт, вы сможете проверить это все самостоятельно.
А выдачу мы начинаем уже с понедельника, то есть послезавтра.
Идем к следующим новостям.
Не менее крутая новость, вот как вот эта система, которую я реализовал, нереально крутая.
Следующая система вам тоже понравится.
У нас заканчивается разработка Android Anti-Detector.
Он будет доступен для всех.
Он будет доступен во всех типах персональных версий.
Ранее было заявлено, что он будет доступен, начиная лишь с типов номер 4 и типов номер 5.
Связано это с небольшими архитектурными ограничениями,
какими не хочу сейчас говорить в вебинаре.
Но теперь было принято решение добавить поддержку Android во все типы персональных версий.
В Patreon вполне возможно,
что поддержка Android появится к концу лета, началу осени текущего года.
Ну а версии для экзаменов, никакого смысла добавлять Android на текущий момент нет.
Если, конечно же, есть какие-то приложения, которые для экзаменов работают только лишь через телефон,
вы можете написать саппортом и, конечно же, мы рассмотрим такой вариант.
По факту скажу ключевые отличия, почему поддержка Android в антидетекте намного лучше,
чем Genymotion, BlueStacks и так далее.
Здесь необходимо разделять очень важные понятия.
Есть понятие симуляция, а есть понятие эмуляция.
Вот все текущие решения, которые есть на рынке, программные я имею в виду,
тот же Genymotion, тот же, например,
BlueStacks это симуляция.
То есть это, конечно же, никакое не реальное устройство
и, более того, огромнейшее количество расхождений с реальными устройствами.
В то время как в нашем случае мы делаем симуляцию,
эмуляцию, прошу прощения, видите, даже я уже запутался в этих параметрах.
Мы эмулируем реальное оборудование и, в частности,
самое главное, что есть только в каждом телефоне,
вы, наверное, думаете, что это какой-нибудь там уникальный показатель.
Нет, нет, нет, это грамотная аппаратная часть,
то есть именно железяка.
Запустить Android можно на обычном VirtualBox.
Вы можете скачать образ Android и запустить его прямо в стандартном Oracle VirtualBox.
Но там не будет железа, там не будет аппаратной части,
там не будет NVRAM, там не будет ни черта того,
что выдает как раз использование каких-либо симуляторов.
Так что в самое ближайшее время, как только мы сейчас разберемся с типом номер 9
и очередным обновлением для всех персональных версий,
мы будем готовы, возможно, пока в бета-тесте,
но, тем не менее, Android поддержка уже будет готова.
Ну а там еще одна система нас ждет.
Я не буду сейчас долго о ней говорить,
но после Android у нас появляется...
Она фактически готова, что Android, что эта система Chrome OS.
Интересная система, о которой мало кто знает,
но, тем не менее, результаты ее работы фантастические
по сравнению с операционной системой Windows.
Идем дальше.
Следующая новость.
Внедрение своей криптовалюты.
И прежде, чем вы закатите глаза и скажете
очередной какой-то непонятный коин,
я хотел бы дать небольшое объяснение.
Мы на прошлом вебинаре говорили про нормы DAC-8
и про текущие методики анонимизации транзакций.
Моей командой был разработан блокчейн.
Именно блокчейн.
Который построен на базе существующей криптовалюты,
существующего блокчейна.
А именно отдельный блокчейн,
который позволяет анонимизировать транзакции.
Ну а еще, если совместить это с нашим замечательным сервисом
по банковским карточкам,
то мы получаем невероятную финансовую свободу.
Но, конечно же, стоит поговорить еще и сразу о плохих вещах.
Плохие вещи заключаются в том,
что...
Я скажу честно,
я не очень слежу за криптовалютами
и эта сфера, она просто есть,
но она не привлекает особого моего внимания.
Но, тем не менее, иногда
с разных, скажем так,
источников,
получаю информацию, что там какой-то блогер
запустил криптовалюту,
в течение нескольких часов
она росла там на несколько тысяч процентов,
потом она скатилась
ниже плинтуса.
И таких фактически я не вижу исключений.
Я посмотрел,
действительно не увидел фактически никаких исключений.
Почему?
Потому что те валюты, они ничем не обеспечены
и они призваны только лишь
собрать денег.
То есть, купите у меня мои фантики
и все.
Вот по факту, как оно есть, как оно работает.
Поэтому в моей системе
я хочу сделать все принципиально иначе.
У нас не является
данная валюта спекулятивной
и ее рост
будет лишь
скажем так,
зависеть от ее популярности.
Никаким образом более.
То есть, никаких
нескольких сотен, тысяч
или даже, я думаю,
даже нескольких десятков иксов
вы можете не увидеть,
поэтому даже покупать ее на старте
вам не обязательно.
И тем более, вам не нужно ее покупать,
если вы не хотите сохранить ваши транзакции
полностью анонимными.
Так что,
может быть, когда-нибудь она станет x2,
может быть, когда-нибудь станет x5,
но это время покажет.
И покажет в первую очередь грамотный
технический функционал.
Валюту не собираюсь особо пиарить.
Почему? Потому что смысла в этом нету.
Повторюсь, здесь в данном случае
необходима именно функциональная
реализация токена,
а не пиар.
И в данном случае пиар
даже не будет на руку.
Объясню почему. Потому что
созданная валюта по факту является
фантиком, который ничего не стоит.
Но,
если о ней будут слишком много знать,
то могут появиться вопросы ко мне.
А мне бы этого конкретно
не хотелось.
Потому что, как показывает
опыт, например,
других валют, которые пытаются
быть анонимными,
их делистят с бирж,
например,
и к создателям всегда вопросы.
Даже к тому же самому Монеро,
если копнуть в сторону команды,
очень много
вопросов может появиться
у обычного пользователя.
Так что пока назовем данный анонс
плейсхолдером.
Ну а как появится валюта,
вы об этом узнаете в телеграм-канале.
И посмотрим.
Я думаю, что этот опыт однозначно
будет важен, поскольку
данная валюта позволит
делать те вещи, которые не всегда
возможно сделать с какой-либо
другой криптовалютой.
Ну, конечно же, анонимные транзакции.
Ну, все. На этом небольшой
блок новостей закончен.
И мы можем приступать к нашей
основной теме. Основная тема
у нас, напоминаю, сегодня
геолокация. Десять основных методик,
которые позволяют изменить
геолокацию пользователя, а также
не только лишь мы сделаем
обзор, но также и разберем,
как эти методики можно подменить.
Правильно, нам же
нужно решение какое-то.
Ну а для тех, кто смотрит мои вебинары
в первый раз, таких людей действительно
у нас много, поскольку счетчик
пользователей у нас уверенно
перешагнул отметку 400 человек.
И это действительно классно.
Я вижу, что на прошлые вебинары
получил действительно большое количество
положительных отзывов.
Так что для тех, кто не совсем знаком
со мной, с моей
работой, я хотел бы представиться.
Это будет первый вебинар, наверное,
в истории, когда мне необходимо представиться.
Кто я такой?
Я Дмитрий Момот, исследователь
в области информационной безопасности.
Основную, точнее не основную,
первую известность свою получил
еще в далеком 2009 году,
когда взламывал
пиратские сервера онлайн MMORPG
и рассказывал
на форумах, как производить
те или иные манипуляции
с данными серверами, а также
как в совершенстве владеть
манипуляцией на
отрезке клиент-сервер.
С 2014 года
моя деятельность
привела меня
в информационную безопасность
в плане оказания услуг.
Услуг людям, которые
не хотят быть замеченными.
И, в частности,
вы можете найти
огромное количество информации
обо мне на одном из форумов под названием
Dark Money.
Сейчас я являюсь владельцем
компании Vector T13 Technologies,
которая недавно стала уже
целым конгломератом, поскольку у нас есть
компания в Украине, компания в Нидерландах
и также компания
в Объединенных Арабских Эмиратах,
в которых я имею честь
быть резидентом.
Так что для тех, кто будет в Дубае,
для наших будущих потенциальных клиентов
вы всегда можете зайти в офис нашей компании,
который расположен в Бурдж-Халифе.
А также
дополнительным бонусом будет то,
что вы сможете полюбоваться великолепной
панорамой прекрасного города Дубай
с высоты 125 этажа.
Именно там расположен наш офис.
Так что пишите саппорта
и буду ждать в гости.
Ну а для наших текущих клиентов
всегда буду рад встретиться
и пропустить несколько стопок мескаля.
Ну а может быть и не несколько,
а немного больше.
Итак, наша геолокация.
Возвращаемся к ней.
Первый, первый, первобытный
метод это геолокация
на основе IP-адресов.
Вот здесь, я думаю,
вам в принципе все понятно.
С данным методом геолокации
в принципе знаком кто угодно.
Это геолокация
с помощью, где главным
идентификатором используется
наш IP-адрес.
IP-адрес проверяется с помощью
публичных баз данных.
Например, таких баз данных, как MaxMind.
Фактически на данную компанию
и на ее геобазы
сейчас
опирается весь мир геолокации.
Ну, фактически
все. Поэтому, если вдруг
пользователи иногда задают
вопрос.
У нас великолепный сервис по
прокси мобильным.
И пользователи иногда используют
различного рода чекеры.
Давайте сейчас как раз этот кейс разберем.
Пользователь покупает
прокси в США.
Заходит на какой-нибудь чекер
и потом предъявляет претензию.
Говорит, ой, а почему у меня
не США, а Северная
Корея? Почему у меня теперь
Ким Чен Ир на весь мой
монитор? А вот здесь есть проблема.
Проблема заключается в том, что
IP-адреса в мире, их чуть больше
4 миллиардов. Количество
устройств, которые подключены к
вашей сети, более 30 миллиардов.
Конечно же, есть надсети,
есть внутренние сети, но
тем не менее, IP-адреса находятся
как будто в большой бетономешалке.
Если некоторые из них являются
статичными на протяжении нескольких
десятков лет, другие очень
часто меняют свое
местоположение. Поэтому
IP-адрес, который в 2020
году, например, принадлежал
Северной Корее, условно говоря,
теперь может принадлежать США.
Поэтому самым лучшим вариантом
для того, чтобы проверить свою
геолокацию, это не использовать
какие-либо чекеры, а просто зайти
на сайт MaxMind,
где вы бесплатно можете проверить
свою геолокацию. Ну а в чем же
причина ложных данных чекеров,
я вам скажу. Дело в том, что
MaxMind также имеет
свои базы данных, которые
утекают в паблик. И вы можете
найти базы данных MaxMind
от 2021 года, 2022, даже
в открытом доступе на GitHub.
Соответственно, для того, чтобы не покупать
базу данных полную, некоторые
владельцы чекеров просто
используют устаревшие
базы. Хотя в то же время MaxMind
предоставляет и на абсолютно
бесплатной основе актуальные базы.
Так вот, когда
какой-нибудь веб-ресурс
хочет определить вашу геолокацию,
все, что ему нужно, это просто
обратиться к базе MaxMind,
и после этого он будет знать,
какую информацию вам показать, например,
или разрешить вам вход на сайт.
Самым простым примером
таким является
букмекерские конторы.
Мы все прекрасно знаем, что, например,
вы не можете перейти на сайт
какой-нибудь букмекерской конторы,
если вы заходите из страны, в которой
букмекерские, точнее,
азартные игры запрещены, например.
Или в которых нет у этой компании лицензии.
Самый простейший
метод этой геолокации.
Тем не менее, данный метод работает
и на текущий момент, и мы постоянно
с ним сталкиваемся ежедневно.
В зависимости от
вашей IP-геолокации нам
веб-ресурс будет предлагать
определенный перевод под наш регион,
например, или же функционал, который
доступен только в нашем регионе
и ни в каком другом.
Однако, помимо IP-адреса
также еще есть
ASN-сеть.
ASN-сеть это,
простыми словами выражаясь,
конгломерат IP-адресов
и сетей.
То есть, ASN-сеть может иметь вид, например,
777,
1059. Всего в мире
чуть больше 300 тысяч
ASN-сетей на текущий момент.
Уже около 350
где-то тысяч
сетей.
Но IP-адресов, соответственно, мы понимаем
4 миллиарда, поэтому все
IP-адреса в мире объединены в разные
ASN-сети по тем или иным
признакам по принадлежности
к определенному провайдеру,
юридическому лицу и так далее.
Так вот, несмотря на то, что
IP-адрес является
якобы главным нашим идентификатором,
тем не менее,
ASN-сеть и ее идентификатор
немного даже важнее,
чем наш IP-адрес.
Потому что по ASN-сетям элементарно
просто определить, когда
IP-адрес принадлежит ботнету.
Точнее, не ботнету, прошу прощения, хостингу.
Какому-либо,
например,
сервису ВПС,
либо же большому хостинг-провайдеру,
такому, например, как DigitalOcean или
Hetzner, у которых свои сети.
И проверка с помощью
ASN позволяет не только проверить
ваш основной IP-адрес,
но также проверить соседние
с вами IP-адреса.
И, соответственно, на этом основании
сделать вывод о вашей реальной
геолокации, а также
о определенных методах,
которые могут к вам быть применены.
То есть, опять же,
если вы заходите из ASN-сети,
которая, например, базируется
в,
условно говоря,
Северной Корее,
и в этой сети одни боты,
соответственно, вам хорошего ничего
не покажут. Не знаю, почему
сегодня я так отношусь
и часто упоминаю Северную Корею.
Обычно я упоминаю Монголию.
Так вот, как можно изменить
ASN, как можно изменить
IP-адрес. Отдельно вы эти параметры
можете изменить только,
если поменяете IP-адрес
на тот, который входит
в состав этой ASN-сети.
Оставить IP-адрес, а изменить
ASN-сеть вы уже не можете, потому что
IP-адрес находится ниже рангом,
чем ASN-сеть. Поэтому самый
простой метод, это просто изменить
IP-адрес. Прокси,
VPN, да что угодно
позволит вам изменить ваш
IP-адрес,
вашу ASN и, соответственно, регион
вашего присутствия.
Данная методика геолокации
до 2007 года
являлась единственной.
То есть, представьте себе, еще не так давно
хотя нет, черт возьми,
давно. 2007 год
был 19 лет назад.
Невероятное время спешить.
Но, тем не менее, это была первая
методика в нашем сегодняшнем вебинаре.
И применяется она как
веб-ресурсами, так и локальным
программным обеспечением. Это
наши два основных субъекта,
которые нас интересуют.
Идем дальше. Следующий метод.
Следующий метод называется у нас
TraceRoad.
Наверняка вы
знаете, что такое TraceRoad, или кто-нибудь
когда-нибудь выполнял данную
команду в командной
строке Windows, либо же Linux.
Эта команда позволяет
вам
узнать, как
идет ваш трафик, через какое
количество узлов.
Соответственно, когда у вас,
например, целевой узел
находится в США,
а вы находитесь, например,
во Вьетнаме,
то ваш
трафик пройдет через,
условно скажем, 12
различных узлов.
А если же целевой к вам ресурс
находится также во Вьетнаме,
в таком случае ваш целевой трафик
может пройти через 4-5
узлов. И также
при выполнении TraceRoad
есть возможность еще и
определить, через какие
конкретно узлы проходит ваш
трафик. И здесь я хотел бы
выделить два интересных момента.
Дело в том, что TraceRoad,
сам по себе, он
он,
скажем так,
работает только лишь локально.
То есть, веб-ресурсы
не могут выполнить данную
процедуру. У них нет
доступа. Ну, даже на обычном
ПК в некоторых случаях
TraceRoad может не работать из-за
правил Firewall. Но,
помимо этого, есть еще один
очень интересный метод,
с которым я хотел бы вас познакомить,
который, в принципе, косвенно может
считать
методом TraceRoad.
Дело в том, что веб-ресурсы,
а вы можете проверить это на примере
сервиса
чекера BrowserLeaks,
в разделе
IP-адреса вы можете увидеть количество
так называемых хопов.
Так вот, веб-ресурсы
по
показателю
вашего TTL,
TimeToLeave,
ваших сетевых пакетов, могут
определить, как далеко от них вы
находитесь. Дело в том,
что наш
TTL,
стандартный TTL,
который формируется нашей операционной
системой, он
имеет значение 128.
Просто 128 единиц. Наверняка
он знаком многим из вас.
И на каждом из узлов,
через которые трафик будет
проходить, этот параметр
TTL будет уменьшаться на
единицу.
Соответственно, если
до необходимого
веб-ресурса доходит пакет
с TTL, например,
118, то веб-ресурс
может сделать вывод, что
трафик прошел через 10
узлов, либо
через 11 узлов, поскольку
ваш роутер добавит
к TTL единицу.
То есть он сделает так, что
ваш TTL будет не 128, а
129 и пошлет пакет уже со
единицами TTL.
Так что это небольшой такой лайфхак,
как можно приблизить себя
к необходимой
локации. Например,
кстати, в моем софте в антидетекте
недавно реализован был такой
функционал. Невероятно простой,
тупой, но тем не менее довольно действенный.
И вы теперь при использовании,
например, VPN
можете,
стандартный VPN вам даст примерно
13-14,
прошу прощения, 13-14 хопов
того же самого браузерликса.
А вы можете уменьшить его до,
условно говоря, одного даже.
Но это больше лабораторные тесты, я не
рекомендую менять меньше, чем на 7
хопов. Но таким образом
вы сможете приблизиться к
необходимому веб-ресурсу, если, например,
он находится, условно говоря, в США,
а вы находитесь во Вьетнаме.
Итак,
возвращаемся к нашему
трейсроуту. Если касаемо
такого подобия
трейсроута
в браузере, я только что
рассказал, что вам необходимо сделать,
просто изменить свой TTL в настройках
операционной системы и таким образом
приблизиться к необходимому клиенту,
то
процедура трейсроут, которая выполняется
через средства
Windows и может быть выполнена любым
программным обеспечением, лечится
очень просто, отключается
ICMP трафик.
Это делается в свойствах Firewall
и уделять этому внимание
особо здесь не нужно, поскольку нужно
просто заблокировать один протокол
и после этого трейсроут
будет невозможен.
Это, кстати, довольно частая политика,
в ней нет ничего аномального,
частая политика различного рода
Firewall, которая идет по умолчанию,
поскольку данная процедура, она
фактически для обычного
рядового пользователя является
бесполезной. Поэтому
подводим небольшой итог.
Трейсроут локальный
может выполнить только локальное
программное обеспечение и лечится
это с помощью правил Firewall.
Ну а
Web Traceroute, если можно его так назвать,
аналог, можно изменить
благодаря изменению параметра
TTL в вашей операционной системе
и работает как на системах под управлением
Windows, так и на системах под
управлением Linux или Mac OS.
Элементарно
просто, но тем не менее невероятно
действенно, потому что если
между вами и вашим замечательным
адресом и искомым
веб-ресурсом будет
находиться 13-14 хопов,
ну ни на какого американца
вы похожи не будете.
Ну вот как ни старайтесь.
Идем дальше. Следующий метод.
Надеюсь, вам интересно.
Следующий метод у нас
DNS. Здесь, я думаю,
все уже все знают,
но я постараюсь вас чем-нибудь
удивить все-таки. Итак,
каким образом можно определить,
что мы используем DNS
и как мы используем, точнее,
определить нашу геолокацию.
Ну, безусловно, понятно,
DNS-сервер имеет свой
IP-адрес и
по аналогии с
геолокацией на основе IP-адреса
из пункта номер один, мы можем провести
запрос,
где этот IP-адрес находится
с базой MaxMind и понять, что мы,
например,
если мы заявляем, что мы используем,
что мы находимся в США по нашему
основному IP-адресу, но наш DNS находится,
например, во Вьетнаме,
то, соответственно, вряд ли такое возможно
в реальности. Но, помимо этого,
есть еще несколько интересных
методик. Методика первая.
Так называемый
DNS-суффикс.
Он отсутствует здесь на слайде,
поэтому вам необходимо просто
воспринять информацию на слух.
Очень часто
интернет-провайдеры
добавляют определенный суффикс
к DNS-запросам.
И этот суффикс
сохраняется вашей операционной
системой и не меняется,
даже если вы используете
VPN.
Простой пример.
Наш замечательный во время проживания
в Нидерландах у меня
провайдер был так называемый
Ziggo.
И этот провайдер Ziggo
оставил свой DNS-суффикс
на моем ПК
и таким образом у меня, я долго
думал, а какого черта у меня
веб-ресурсы открываются на пидерландском?
А оказывается, это у меня
великолепнейший DNS-суффикс,
который меня автоматически сообщал
другому DNS-серверу, к которому я
обращался, что я обращаюсь
из Нидерландов.
Ну, это так, немного утрировал
и, скажем так,
обобщил, но суть является такой.
Поэтому рекомендую в настройках
просто взять, ввести
в командной строке команду
ipconfig
и увидеть, соответственно,
есть ли у вас DNS-суффикс или его нет.
Он будет отдельным пунктом выделен.
Данный DNS-суффикс всегда
будет добавляться к
DNS-запросам, которые вы будете
отправлять.
Но, помимо этого, есть еще
несколько интересных моментов.
Есть момент такого, так называемого
eDNS-клиента.
О нем некоторые
люди делали
целые расследования, как
eDNS важен и так далее.
По факту я вам скажу, по своей практике
я почему-то не уделяю ему
особого внимания, потому что у меня
ни разу не получалось найти
хотя бы одного
клиента, где это нормально работало.
Но, тем не менее, о нем просто
обязан напомнить, как вскользь.
Чем же еще
нас может порадовать наш DNS?
Дело в том, что
в зависимости от того,
как установлен наш браузер,
то есть, например, вы установили браузер
в одной стране, точнее,
в вашей родной стране, например, во Вьетнаме,
затем вы внесли себе
прокси или же VPN
в США, то ваши
DNS-запросы могут все равно
идти через вьетнамские
DNS. Почему?
Дело в том, что в самих браузерах есть
по умолчанию список
из DNS-серверов, к которым они
обращаются. То есть за
хардкоденные сервера.
В частности, очень это любит делать
Google. Поэтому одна из
простейших методик, которая
позволяет деанонимизировать
пользователя и показать его
реальный DNS.
Но также для локального
программного обеспечения есть
возможность использовать еще один
дополнительный параметр.
Это так называемый
DNS-кэш.
DNS-кэш, который находится на
вашем компьютере и история
ваших DNS, которая может быть использована
локальным программным обеспечением
для того, чтобы понять, где вы
находитесь. В частности, также
это может являться еще и
источником утечки информации
о том, как вы изменяли свое
местоположение. Приведу пример.
Вы создали,
например,
у вас ноутбук.
Отдельный ноутбук, который
подключен, например, к какому-нибудь
мощному роутеру, на котором
установлен VPN. Вроде бы
все классно, вроде бы все хорошо.
Но если в какой-то момент
на вашем
роутере
кексик или VPN пропал,
что может происходить?
У вас, если не настроены
правила фильтрации или
не настроен тот же самый
kill switch, то ваш ноутбук
он все равно пойдет в сеть.
Несмотря на то, что вы не будете серфить
на нем или что-нибудь делать,
все равно операционная система будет в сеть ломиться.
И, соответственно,
в логах операционной
системы
будет упоминание о том, что
в такой-то такой-то момент
DNS адрес
переприсвоен на новый.
И, соответственно,
затем, подняв эти логи,
есть возможность определить
с помощью локального программного обеспечения,
что имела место
быть смена
DNS. И только
человек, который знает, что эти логи нужно
либо отключить, либо почистить,
сможет обойти такой
примитивнейший, но тем не менее
довольно действенный детект, потому что
о нем просто мало кто знает.
Но, тем не менее, операционная система хранит
в себе много различных секретов,
на которые я рекомендую
обратить ваше внимание и постараюсь
рассказать вам о них максимально.
Вывод по поводу DNS.
Изменение геолокации
с помощью DNS лечится
элементарно просто.
Вы можете сменить ваш DNS,
но если будете менять его, меняйте его
хотя бы правильно. Каким образом
можно это сделать? Либо
на удачу,
что, конечно же, исключено, потому что
проще в лотерею выиграть, наверное.
Вы можете вбить IP-адрес
вашего,
какой-нибудь IP
из подсети вашего проксика.
Либо же, если вы используете VPN,
соответственно, вам, скорее всего,
VPN-провайдер даст уже
DNS. Но есть еще
один вариант, которым я рекомендую
воспользоваться. На сервисе
DetectExpert вы можете
внести свой IP-адрес
и затем получить
для него DNS.
При этом это все абсолютно бесплатно.
Так что можете использовать.
Но это для веб-ресурсов.
А если же вы работаете с локальным
программным обеспечением, то вам необходимо
сделать то же самое, но плюс
все-таки рекомендую также еще
и очистить журналы,
и очистить полностью
весь DNS-кэш.
Благо для этого есть командная строка,
которая позволяет это сделать всего лишь
парой команд.
Ну а мы продолжаем. И это был только лишь
третий метод.
Четвертый метод уже более сложный,
более технологичный,
и он построен чисто на
физическом взаимодействии.
В данном случае это
GPS-модуль. Что такое
GPS-модуль, я думаю, вы все прекрасно знаете,
поскольку пользуетесь
современной техникой, современными
телефонами, но также
наверняка вы знаете,
что во многих ПК
также присутствует GPS-модуль,
который принимает
сигналы со спутника
и, соответственно, показывает
вашу геолокацию.
Вот это очень серьезная и очень
сложная вещь. Объясню почему.
Потому что,
если у вас такой модуль физически есть
в вашем ПК,
обмануть его крайне сложно.
Действительно крайне сложно.
Для тех, кто...
Давайте приведем пример.
Геолокация на
iPhone, условно говоря.
Сложно подменить.
Возможно, да.
С помощью специализированного
программного обеспечения,
если перевести, например,
приложение в
режим разработчик.
Но для стандартных ПК,
для ПК на Windows или Linux
такого программного обеспечения
лично я, например, не встречал.
Если вы встречали, напишите
в комментариях к данному видео.
Какие же есть варианты?
Вариантов есть всего-навсего два.
Первый вариант
просто-напросто отключить данное устройство.
В этом, в принципе, особой
аномалии нет.
Но, конечно же, это не очень желательно.
Поскольку GPS-модуль
и его наличие,
если он у вас есть в системе,
скрыть не получится.
Даже если вы устройство отключите,
все равно оно будет видно.
Поэтому мы переходим к технике номер два.
Если вам необходимо именно изменить
геолокацию с помощью GPS,
например, ваш софт
требует наличие GPS-модуля,
то в таком случае
вы можете воспользоваться
антидетектом от Vector T13,
поскольку
в моем софте я реализовал
полностью независимое устройство,
которое эмулирует
GPS-сигналы.
Плюс ко всему
в последнем обновлении
добавлена более точная
геопозиция.
То есть вместо четырех знаков
после запятой у нас теперь семь знаков,
которые позволяют вычислить
геолокацию вплоть до одного метра.
А также добавлены небольшие
смещения геолокации,
которые позволяют
полностью эмулировать
реальные данные со спутника.
Поскольку нужно понимать,
что данные со спутника
все равно могут варьироваться.
И раньше у нас не было этого функционала.
Геопозиция была статична
все время на протяжении всей жизни
виртуальной машины.
Но сейчас она получает небольшой люфт,
небольшое смещение
в рамках
нескольких метров,
что полностью эмулирует
реальное устройство.
Повторюсь,
на обычных ПК
каких-либо методик подменить
сигналы на физическом чипе
к сожалению я на текущий момент
не знаю.
Поэтому выбора два.
Либо же использовать устройство
без GPS модуля,
например T13,
где можно подменить геолокацию
без каких-либо проблем.
Кстати, в частности,
сервис Windows Maps
как раз основывается
на этой геолокации.
И все веб-ресурсы
могут использовать
данные с вашего GPS модуля
при получении доступа
к Geolocation API.
Проверку вы можете произвести
опять же на веб-ресурсе
BrowserLeaks
геопозиция, как вариант.
Ну, идем дальше.
Следующий метод.
Стараюсь сегодня не очень много времени
уделять
таким глубоким
материям, поскольку
прошлый вебинар у нас затянулся
аж на три часа.
В этом вебинаре я хочу,
чтобы вы максимум уложились
в два часа и не утомлять вас
этим прекрасным субботним вечером.
Метод геолокации номер пять.
Геолокация с помощью
истории Windows Update.
Данный метод
доступен только для
операционной системы Windows.
И он позволяет
определить, где и когда
обновлялся ваш
ваша копия
операционной системы Windows.
Дело в том, что
Windows автоматически проверяет
вашу геолокацию
и он хочет
загрузить
обновление максимально быстро
на ваш ПК.
Соответственно, он будет проверять,
к каким серверам ему подключиться.
И, условно говоря,
в журналах он
очень может наследить.
Даже не может, а он всегда наследит.
Поэтому будет известно,
откуда было скачано
какое обновление.
Поскольку у Microsoft есть
мало того, что региональные сервера,
но также Microsoft
хорошо сотрудничает с системой
под названием Akamai.
Системой, которую мы будем
также сегодня разбирать немного позже.
Но благодаря их сотрудничеству
в операционной системе
Windows сохраняются логи,
откуда какое
обновление было загружено.
И, соответственно, локальное
программное обеспечение может получить
доступ к данным
журналам и определить
откуда, когда
загружалось данное обновление.
И в данном случае уже будет
очень сложно доказать,
что, например,
вы, как житель США, по какой-то причине
решили загрузить
себе
обновление на ваш десктопный ПК
из
того же самого Вьетнама или из
Северной Кореи, условно.
Поэтому небольшой такой детект,
который является невероятно простым,
но поскольку о нем
мало кто знает,
этот детект очень
часто может быть причиной того,
что, например, ваше
экзаменационное программное обеспечение
будет отказывать
вам в
предоставлении услуг.
Поскольку экзаменационные программы,
такие как, например, тот же самый
Respondus Lockdown Browser,
либо же Proctorio
Safe Exam Browser,
они
пользуются
системами логирования Windows
чтобы определить косвенными методами
вашу геолокацию.
И чтобы не было такого, что,
условно говоря, вы уехали
в другую страну по непонятной причине
сдавать экзамен.
Так что обратите внимание на это.
Для веб-ресурсов данный метод
недоступен, но он доступен
для локального программного обеспечения.
И почистить,
точнее изменить
данную геолокацию
очень просто.
Вы можете либо отредактировать логи и вбить
те сервера Windows,
которые вам необходимы,
те сервера Microsoft, прошу прощения,
либо же просто очистить эти логи,
что также не будет являться
критическим детектом
и позволит вам обойти
ту или иную систему,
которая использует логирование
как методику геолокации.
Следующая тема.
Следующая тема
вообще интересная.
Это система под названием MDNS.
Наверняка
многие из вас,
когда смотрят YouTube,
видят картинку Chromecast,
точнее такую небольшую иконку.
И эта небольшая иконка
позволяет транслировать то,
что вы смотрите на вашем телефоне
либо же на вашем ПК,
на телевизор
либо же на какие-либо другие устройства.
Данная система
имеет в своей основе
технологию под названием
MDNS.
Для всех нас она
доступна следующим образом.
По-простому скажу.
Веб-ресурс может отсканировать
нашу локальную сеть и определить
сколько у нас устройств.
Мы об этом уже говорили и показывали
в разделе браузерного фингерпринтинга.
Но помимо того,
что веб-ресурс может увидеть
только локальные IP-адреса,
если сканирование будет выполнено
изнутри сети,
то есть, например,
локальным программным обеспечением,
он позволяет получить
внешний IP-адрес устройства.
А теперь перевожу все это
на человекочитабельный язык.
Дело в том, что
если вы, подключившись
к своему родному Wi-Fi,
используете VPN,
на котором вы хотите сказать,
что вы чистокровный американец,
но ваш телевизор,
находящийся в соседней комнате
Smart TV
подключен к этому же роутеру,
например, тот же самый VPN или Proxy
не использует, а использует
стандартное подключение к сети,
то благодаря технологии mDNS
локальное программное обеспечение,
запущенное на ПК,
на котором применены средства анонимизации,
может определить внешний IP-адрес
устройства, на котором такие методы
не применены. Иными словами,
локальное ПО
обойдет ваш VPN
и Proxy, если спросят
IP-адрес у телевизора.
Это так, по-простому.
Механика довольно сложная реализация
этого всего, но сложная в плане
понимания устройства сети.
А по факту реализовать это
пара пустяков. Так что
о таком методе вам необходимо знать
и
если, повторюсь,
веб-ресурсы могут выполнить
mDNS сканирование
только лишь
внутренних IP-адресов,
то есть они увидят, сколько у вас
устройств в вашей сети. Любой
веб-ресурс может это сделать.
И тест, на всякий случай,
я не помню, писал на прошлом
вебинаре или нет.
Сейчас отправлю
в чат.
Вот, можете, в принципе, на данном
веб-ресурсе это все проверить.
Ну, вообще, фактически это не является
какой-то высшей материей.
Можете зайти на GitHub и можно
найти, в принципе, большое количество
такого рода тестов.
Так вот, если веб-ресурс может
лишь определить внутренние
IP-адреса и составить, условно говоря,
ваш фингерпринтинг такого плана,
то локальное программное обеспечение
может определить уже реальные
IP-адреса внешние.
Поэтому рекомендуется,
конечно же, сделать следующее.
Есть два варианта.
Первый вариант довольно простой.
Вы можете
просто отключить службу
mDNS.
Отключается данная служба
в стойках файрволла.
В любой операционной системе
вы можете зайти и прямо найти
в файрволле правила mDNS.
Они так и называются.
Вот, это вариант номер один.
Вариант номер два.
Самый предпочтительный
изолировать работу от вашей реальной жизни.
Вот это самый лучший вариант,
который вы можете только себе представить.
Хотя интересно, если заходить
в тонкие материи,
к чему лучше отнесется веб-ресурс?
Если в вашей сети найдет еще
один человек,
или же, если в вашей сети
не найдет ни одного.
Но это так.
Почва для размышлений
и, можно сказать так, домашняя работа.
А сейчас мы переходим
к методу номер семь.
И после него сделаем
буквально 5-7 минутный перерывчик.
Выпьем чаю, покурим
и вернемся, поскольку у нас
еще будет очень много информации.
Итак, метод номер семь.
Метод номер семь
— это любимый Akamai.
Для тех, кто не совсем знаком
с данной системой, хотелось бы
рассказать, что Akamai — это самый
большой контент-провайдер в мире.
Иными словами, CDN-сеть.
Content Delivery Network.
Более 200 000 серверов
по всему миру.
Когда вы смотрите Netflix,
когда вы загружаете игрушечку
со Steam, когда вы
загружаете обновления Windows,
вы используете
сервера Akamai. Практически
во всех 100% случаев, наверное,
вы используете сервера Akamai.
И в данном случае
Akamai может,
помимо того, что повелевать
всем миром контента, если, условно говоря,
с Akamai что-то случится,
то будет очень большая проблема
во всем интернете, но у Akamai
также имеется еще и несколько
дополнительных интересных возможностей.
Возможности эти связаны
с тем, что Akamai очень
много денег
вкладывает в создание
своей антифрауд-системы.
В частности, они сделали великолепнейший
продукт, один из самых
сильных, но по масштабам
самый большой, наверное. По силе и по
ноу-хау я бы еще подумал.
Они сделали свой
Bot Guard. Великолепнейший
продукт, в частности,
про него я уже рассказывал
на предыдущих вебинарах, поэтому повторяться
не буду. Для тех, кого интересует,
более 1,3
миллионов веб-ресурсов подключены
к Akamai. И, в частности, одним из
простых детектов бота является
то, что у IP-адреса имеется
своя репутация. Что с этого
IP-адреса загружали? Если с этого
IP-адреса только лишь устанавливали
браузер,
например, установили с этого
IP-адреса
100 раз браузер за последний месяц,
ну, значит, наверное, с этим
IP-адресом что-то не совсем так.
А если с этого IP-адреса, например,
смотрели порно,
или же загружали какие-нибудь обновления
Windows, да, вопросов нет.
То классно, к данному IP-адресу
имеется доверие. Но это простая
логика, скажем так.
Бот Гуарда, кому интересно, зайдите
в YouTube и найдите более детальное
объяснение. Но
у Akamai есть еще система,
о которой я ранее не говорил.
Эта система называется Пинг-понг.
И не путать с тем Пинг-понгом,
который вы можете увидеть
в тайских подворотнях. Здесь Пинг-понг
намного серьезнее. Дело в том,
что вы, находясь за
VPN, за проксиком,
вы не можете обмануть
физику. К сожалению,
мы пока не можем этого сделать.
Может быть, в будущем сможем, но не сейчас.
И если вы находитесь,
как и я, например, в замечательном,
прекрасном Дубае, но
хотите показать, что вы являетесь
пользователем США, окей.
Может быть, у вас это пройдет.
Но не в случае с Akamai.
Akamai будет, поскольку имеет
огромную сеть серверов,
он может сделать различного
рода запросы к вам.
То есть он может с вами играться
с разных серверов,
посылая вам вопросы, получая
ответы. И таким образом он
может определить, где
ответ придет быстрее, где
ответ придет дольше.
И, соответственно,
если, условно говоря, вы бы находились в США,
то параметр,
который мы все знаем под названием
Latency, а на всякий случай
я рекомендую
проверить данный параметр на
чекере Cloudflare,
так вот,
вы можете
сбился с мысли.
Так вот,
если вы находитесь, условно говоря,
в Дубае,
посещаете веб-ресурс,
который находится в США,
используете прокси США,
то параметр Latency, который будет
указывать, условно говоря,
можно так его назвать, задержка,
он будет
намного выше, чем
у реального пользователя из США.
Если сделать к вам запрос
из Индии, или из Омана,
или из Саудовской Аравии,
то параметр Latency будет
намного ниже, и будет
чем у пользователя из США.
И, таким образом, условно говоря,
можно сделать триангуляцию
за счет проверки вас
из различных источников.
Метод очень
действенный, действительно, поскольку
по
заявлениям представителей компании
они позволяют определить
геолокацию пользователя за
VPN и прокси
вплоть до города.
То есть,
определить страну это уже классно,
но определить город это, конечно же,
великолепно. Но достигается это
все за счет именно огромной сети
серверов и
грамотного позиционирования.
Так что обязательно
обратите на это внимание. Данная
методика, она доступна и
веб-ресурсам, и локальному
обеспечению. Поскольку
может выполняться со всех сторон
и, таким образом,
деанонимизация ваша
не составит большого
труда. Ну, повторюсь, вплоть до
одного города.
И
здесь не спасет ни прокси, ни
VPN. Есть несколько хитростей,
конечно, которые
про которые хотелось бы рассказать.
Хитрость номер один,
которая малореализуема
на практике, но
тем не менее, я бы хотел о ней
как минимум упомянуть.
Дело в том, что
можно
себя, можно обмануть
немного физику, можно
себя переместить, если
одновременно использовать
несколько VPN.
Бред сумасшедшего, правда?
Но, если вы
вдумаетесь над тем, что я сказал,
наверняка вы сможете найти решение.
Представьте себе, что ваш трафик
идет не через один
IP-адрес, точнее, не через
один туннель, а идет сразу
через несколько туннелей.
Я не беру сейчас отдельные VPN,
поскольку у вас тогда было бы три разных
IP-адреса, и маршрутизация
бы сошла с ума. Нет.
Но дело в том, что есть
определенная методика,
с помощью которой вы можете
увеличить скорость вашего VPN
и снизить параметр лайтенси,
если подключитесь к одному
VPN несколько раз.
Ну, при условии, конечно же, что
этот VPN будет находиться на сервере,
который более-менее хотя бы быстрый.
Но это так, домашнее задание
для исследователей.
Если будет интересно, может быть, я покажу
на практике, потому что
по факту звучит как полный
бред. Но, тем не менее,
у меня это реализовать получилось. Так что,
наверняка, получится и у вас.
Но самым простым
методом, если не хотите
себе парить голову
таким идиотизмом,
а если вы не ботаник,
то по-другому это как идиотизм не назвать,
является очень простое
решение. Просто
используйте удаленные рабочие
сервера. Ведь так замечательно,
когда вы возьмете
себе, работаете по США,
арендуете себе там удаленный
физический сервер, поставьте на него
свои антидетекты, и будет вам
счастье, вы увидите, насколько
серьезно у вас
увеличится ваша производительность.
Поскольку в данном случае общение
будет выполняться между
вашим сервером в США, вашим
прокси в США и вашим
веб-ресурсом в США.
А вы, который находится во Вьетнаме,
вы будете общаться с вашим
сервером уже по совершенно другому
протоколу, по протоколу РДП, например.
И вам, соответственно, не нужно будет
каким-либо образом заморачиваться
о том, что
у вас,
например, тот же самый параметр
latency, он очень
очень
очень высокий.
Так что берите это как
бесплатный совет.
Ну и на текущий момент
у нас уже прошел первый час
нашего вебинара,
поэтому сделаем небольшой
буквально 5-7 минутный перерыв,
и затем
продолжим наш
продолжим наш вебинар.
У меня есть для вас кое-что еще
очень-очень интересное.
Ну и, конечно же, не стоит забывать про
GeoComply, мы сегодня
про него будем отдельно говорить,
про эту великолепную систему,
и как с ней работать.
Ну а пока делаем перерыв
и немного музыки. Была возможность
немного отдохнуть
от впитывания знаний,
и мы можем продолжать наш
сегодняшний вебинар.
Следующая методика —
методика геолокации номер 8.
Является из всех представленных
сегодня методик самой простой,
но, тем не менее, невероятно
действенной, и для меня до сих пор
остается загадкой, почему пользователи
о ней либо не знают,
либо пытаются ее всячески
игнорировать, поскольку
в большинстве случаев как раз это
являлось причиной каких-либо проблем.
Это так называемая методика
геолокации с помощью
Ping-интерфейса.
Сразу хотелось бы сказать, что данная методика
недоступна для веб-ресурсов,
но доступна для браузеров.
Что это такое? Итак, представимся,
что вы
на своем ПК запускаете
VPN, и даже
после этого вы переходите еще
на какой-нибудь сайт-чекер,
который показывает, что действительно вы
находитесь теперь в США, и все
классно, все окей. Но
вы же
не запустили
VPN, например,
вы же не вытащили у себя из компьютера
сетевую карту, правильно?
Вы, наверное, все-таки ее
используете, вашу реальную сетевую карту,
с помощью которой вы подключаетесь к сети
интернет. А значит, соответственно,
у нас простейший метод
детекта — это опрос
всех сетевых интерфейсов.
Все. То есть, фактически,
если вы запустили VPN,
любое локальное программное обеспечение,
проведя опрос
находящихся у вас на ПК сетевых
интерфейсов, может определить, что
один IP-адрес у вас из
США, а другой IP-адрес
у вас из Вьетнама. Условно
говоря, то есть вашего родного
IP-адреса.
И данная методика применима
как для локального программного обеспечения,
так и не
для веб-ресурсов, но для браузера.
Объясню, почему сразу же говорю
для браузера. Дело в том, что любимый
всеми нами браузер
Chrome, который фактически
является на текущий момент
практически безальтернативным,
он
очень любит эту методику. И в процессе
своей работы он опрашивает
интерфейсы
на предмет наличия
внешних IP-адресов.
Данная методика позволяет
экосистеме Google
всегда знать, что у такого-то
пользователя, а идентифицирует
она вас с помощью заголовков
xclientdata,
она обращает внимание на то,
что у такого-то пользователя
всегда имеется несколько IP-адресов
из разных частей
мира. И поэтому в данном
случае опять же
сервер в США
является великолепной методикой,
но если вы не хотите тратиться
на это, то в таком случае
вам подойдет либо
использование антидетект
роутера,
к которому подключится ваш ПК,
либо же использование физического
роутера, где
соответственно будет установлен
прокси, либо же VPN.
Таким образом у вас на компьютере
будет всего одно сетевое подключение,
реальное, по которому вы будете
подключаться уже к роутеру
и так далее.
Данная методика
очень широко применяется
и всегда
является мастхевом
во всех системах анонимности.
Абсолютно во всех.
То есть если мы говорим об анонимности,
где VPN запускается как отдельное
сетевое соединение,
то кто такую систему анонимности
придумал? Полный идиот.
Точнее кто ее реализовал.
Конечно есть некоторые исключения,
но тем не менее в большинстве случаев
это именно так.
Потому что любое локальное
программное обеспечение и также браузеры
всегда определят ваш
реальный IP-адрес за счет опроса
сетевых интерфейсов.
Так что не забывайте об этом просто
в следующий раз, когда будете
работать с теми или иными
ресурсами. И то, что
например ваше текущее
программное обеспечение не использует
эту методику, абсолютно не значит, что оно
будет использовать ее через некоторое время.
Поскольку методика древняя,
но тем не менее невероятно
действенная, поскольку о ней практически
никто не говорит. Я не видел даже упоминаний
со стороны каких-нибудь технарей
о том, что данная методика
стоит какого-либо внимания.
Так что обращаю на нее ваше
внимание теперь.
Итак, идем дальше.
Геолокация.
Метод номер 9.
С помощью Bluetooth.
Наверняка в ваших телефонах вы
часто используете Bluetooth,
либо же, например, когда вы
ходите по большому супермаркету,
очень часто можно скачать программное обеспечение,
которое позволит вам ориентироваться
в данном супермаркете.
Такое происходит с помощью
технологии Bluetooth.
Если вы используете AirTag,
то есть, например, Apple Tag или же
какие-либо еще другие вариации
таких меток,
то там используется также
геолокация на основе Bluetooth.
Используется так называемый
Bluetooth-маячки.
Мы не будем сейчас
слишком глубоко нырять в данную
тему, поскольку антифрод
системами Bluetooth-геолокация
используется только на телефонах.
Но, тем не менее, возможность
ее применения существует как на
реальных ПК. Прошу прощения,
здесь я допустил
одну неточность.
Не только на телефонах, но и
планшетах. Вот это очень важно.
Но, а на реальных
ПК под управлением, опять же,
на операционной системе Windows,
на десктопах использовать
геолокацию с помощью Bluetooth является
абсолютно глупой затеей,
поскольку Bluetooth имеет
все-таки
очень малую
силу сигнала и малую
зону покрытия. Однако,
существует расследование,
где, благодаря
использованию Bluetooth-геолокации
и находящихся рядом смежных
устройств, была возможность
определить локацию реальности
реального пользователя.
Данные кейсы связаны, в основном,
с спецслужбами Китая и просочились
в сеть либо специально,
либо же из-за каких-либо
утечек.
Также, данная методика
использует
спецслужбы по всему миру,
поскольку ваш телефон,
он может сканировать все,
что находится вокруг и, соответственно,
получать доступ к
геолокации других устройств
от реальных пользователей, даже не
несмотря на то, что ваше устройство может
быть якобы псевдоанонимным.
Но, в контексте
нас это не очень интересует,
потому что, повторюсь,
много программного обеспечения,
которое использует методику Bluetooth-геолокации,
я не встречал.
Но, по простому,
простыми словами,
запущенная
Bluetooth-геолокация на устройстве,
которое поддерживает Bluetooth,
может отсканировать находящиеся
вокруг вас устройства,
и, таким образом,
определить, где конкретно вы
находитесь.
Ну, фактически, вот
все, что можно сказать без
каких-либо тонких материй, потому что
мало заслуживает данная
тематика глубокого
обсуждения, в отличие от тематики
за номером 10,
финальной тематики нашего сегодняшнего
вебинара. И я подозреваю, что многие
из вас пришли как раз именно
из-за этой темы.
Геолокация с помощью
Wi-Fi.
Геолокация с помощью Wi-Fi является
на текущий момент самым
технологичным,
высокотехнологичным, точнее,
и самым наиболее
широко распространенным методом
геолокации пользователя.
Поскольку она применяется
браузером, локальным
программным обеспечением,
операционной системой Windows
и множеством-множеством других
приложений.
Фишка данной методики заключается
в том, что ее очень сложно
побороть, но тем не менее
можно. Какими методами ее можно
побороть, мы с вами сейчас рассмотрим.
Но для начала немного теории.
Что же такое Wi-Fi
Треангуляция?
Когда вы запускаете
ваше Wi-Fi устройство, будь то
модуль в вашем телефоне,
либо модуль в вашем компьютере,
происходит сканирование
окружающих Wi-Fi сетей.
Есть возможность получить информацию
следующего характера
SSID
То есть
название вашей сети.
Название всех окружающих сетей.
У каждой сети есть свой
SSID. И он есть либо
в том виде,
в котором мы его видим,
либо он скрыт.
Это называется уже скрытая сеть.
То есть по факту скрытая сеть
отличается только лишь отсутствием
параметра SSID.
Ну, если можно так назвать,
отрицательный, наверное.
Будем говорить, что его нету,
потому что иначе я вас запутаю.
SSID может присутствовать,
может отсутствовать.
Это нормально. Но это является
идентификатором сети,
которая подключается,
которая находится рядом
с вашим устройством.
Второй идентификатор
это идентификатор BSSID.
Это MAC-адрес.
Вы думаете, что MAC-адрес
в данном случае это тот MAC-адрес,
который вы вводите, когда вы
настраиваете свой роутер в первый раз.
На самом деле нет.
У Wi-Fi роутера может быть несколько MAC-адресов.
Это первый MAC-адрес.
Это MAC-адрес вашего,
условно говоря, сетевого порта,
вашей сетевой карты,
к которой подключается кабель интернета.
Вот его как раз вы можете изменить.
А остальные MAC-адреса уже практически
недоступны для изменения.
Если у вас несколько модулей Wi-Fi,
то в данном случае
у вас будет несколько
MAC-адресов.
И в большинстве роутеров
вы изменить их не можете
с помощью панели управления.
Третьим сигналом
и третьим идентификатором сети
является уровень сигнала.
Четвертым идентификатором
является канал.
То есть, например,
2,4 ГГц,
либо канал №6,
или 11,5 ГГц.
И также
наличие шифрования.
Вот этот весь стек такой,
он формирует из себя информацию
о Wi-Fi сети.
И все Wi-Fi сети,
которые окружают вас,
они имеют данную информацию.
За исключением скрытых сетей,
которые только не имеют SSID.
Но, тем не менее, они все равно видны
любому сканирующему устройству.
Соответственно, получив информацию
об окружающих вас Wi-Fi сетях,
локальное программное обеспечение,
либо же браузер,
либо же веб-ресурс,
могут сделать запрос
к одной из публичных баз,
в которой хранится информация
о всемирных Wi-Fi сетях.
Это может быть самым простым вариантом,
это может быть Google Geolocation API.
В частности,
у меня на веб-ресурсе
DetectExpert есть утилита
под названием Spy Wi-Fi.
Утилита Spy Wi-Fi
проводит все эти манипуляции,
абсолютно бесплатно,
без регистрации и без SMS.
Вы можете скачать ее,
она получит список окружающих вас Wi-Fi сетей,
затем сделает запрос в Google,
после чего вернет вам
ваше точное местоположение,
а также радиус точности обнаружения.
Радиус точности обнаружения
это важнейший параметр,
поскольку при неправильной
эмуляции Wi-Fi сетей
радиус обнаружения
может быть, например,
несколько километров,
и это может являться аномалией
и отсутствовать в реальном мире.
Вот этот простейший метод,
а по факту он действительно
является очень простым,
собрали информацию,
отправили в Google,
получили ответ.
Все.
Вот этот простейший метод
является на текущий момент
для многих пользователей
святым граалем.
Почему?
Потому что
многие банки используют
такую же систему.
И что интересно,
почему-то
множество этих банков
находится в Бразилии.
Бразилия, Аргентина и так далее.
Фактически все клиент-банки,
с которыми я работал,
используют геолокацию
с помощью Wi-Fi.
Непонятно почему,
в других странах я это
особо не встречал, но банковская сеть
Меркадо Паугу,
Меркадо Либре используют
Wi-Fi геолокацию для определения
геолокации пользователя.
Возможно это связано
с похищением людей,
возможно еще с чем-то,
кто знает, но тем не менее
факт остается фактом.
И благодаря тому, что
у Wi-Fi сети есть такой параметр
как сила сигнала,
то коррелируя данные
можно произвести триангуляцию
и понять, где, условно говоря,
вы находитесь в середине,
и вокруг вас сверху, снизу,
сбоку, спереди, сзади
находятся различные Wi-Fi сети.
И благодаря определению силы
сигнала до этих Wi-Fi сетей
есть возможность определить
вашу геолокацию с точностью
до нескольких метров.
Вообще как бы определяют
до 30 сантиметров, вроде бы как,
но по факту доказано
только лишь до одного метра,
что в принципе является
отличной методикой
геолокации.
И в частности
хотелось бы объяснить
еще один очень важный момент,
который касается
этой геолокации.
То, что мы с вами сейчас обсуждали,
это Wi-Fi геолокация.
В принципе,
подменить ее довольно просто.
Как ее подменить,
я вам сегодня расскажу и покажу.
Но есть еще
один метод.
И этот метод вот сейчас
находится на ваших экранах.
До этого я
рассказал про 9 основных
методик геолокации.
Можно было выделить бы еще несколько,
но они являются слишком косвенными
и особого внимания не заслуживают.
Но если проводить аналогию,
то есть целый
комплекс, который называется
GeoGuard
от компании Geocomply.
Так вот,
данное, это не является
отдельной методикой,
это является, скажем так,
целым стэком методик,
поскольку использует практически все,
что мы сегодня с вами обсуждали.
GeoGuard
это программное обеспечение,
которое устанавливается на компьютер
пользователя для того, чтобы определить
его четкую геолокацию и, соответственно,
разрешить либо запретить
ему выполнение
тех или иных операций
на стороне веб-ресурса, либо же
другого локального программного обеспечения.
В частности, я привел пример, например,
с онлайн-платформами
для гэмблинга.
Самый яркий пример,
когда я познакомился с Geocomply,
это был 2021 год,
тогда
все искали решение по поводу
работы с Geocomply
и фактически я его нашел
буквально за несколько дней.
Использовалось
данное решение в следующем ключе.
В
новом провайдере B365
была акция,
что новые аккаунты
получали по 500 долларов
FreeDepot.
То есть,
регистрируешь аккаунт, получаешь 500 долларов
на этот аккаунт.
Но необходимо было быть четко
пользователем из
штата Нью-Джерси.
И почему
такая причина? Неужели
какие-то пользователи штата Нью-Джерси
привилегированы
к такому плану?
На самом деле,
будь на то воля B365,
они бы разрешили вам
заходить откуда угодно.
С любого IP-адреса только заходите.
Фишка заключается в том,
что когда букмекерская компания
получает лицензию и
выходит на какой-то новый рынок,
они хотят, конечно же, привлечь
пользователей от других
букмекерских компаний, которые уже
на этом рынке существуют.
Здесь можно видеть огромные,
действительно большие акции.
По моему мнению, самым большим,
самым рекордсменом была
букмекерская компания William Hill,
которая давала
2021 доллар
за регистрацию
нового аккаунта.
То есть довольно-таки неплохая сумма,
если вы понимаете, как это правильно
масштабировать.
Но, в частности, хотелось бы
упомянуть о том, что компании
в данном случае не преследуют цель
вашей деанонимизации
и так далее. Они, к сожалению,
должны подчиняться местным законам.
И если есть штат,
в котором они получают,
получили лицензию,
и есть штаты, в которых их деятельность
не лицензирована, то в случае,
если они будут предоставлять свои
услуги в штатах, в которых их деятельность
не лицензирована,
они будут нарушать федеральный закон.
А, соответственно, к ним
будут применены санкции,
судебные расследования и так далее,
в общем, огромнейший, огромнейший
геморрой.
И для того, чтобы спастись от этого
геморроя, компании используют
различного рода решения.
Есть два самых популярных
решения на рынке. Решение
XPoint, менее популярное,
и решение GeoGuard
от компании GeoComply, которое является
самым популярным. Решение
GeoGuard позволяет использовать
целый стек проверок,
проверок на предмет
самого IP-адреса
проверок на использование VPN или
прокси, проверок на предмет
использования сетевых аномалий
в настройках ПК
пользователя, на предмет
манипуляций с DNS,
на предмет манипуляций
с скрытыми прокси,
то есть когда, например,
компьютер используется в качестве
части ботнета, например.
И также, конечно же, стоит
упомянуть, что они проверяют еще
и нашу
операционную систему. Но об этом немного
позже, когда мы перейдем в раздел
детектора виртуальных машин.
И по факту система GeoGuard
имеет три основные
состояния.
Состояние разрешить, состояние
запретить и состояние
перенаправить. Состояние
перенаправить вызывает наиболее
количество вопросов, поскольку состояние
перенаправить встречается очень редко.
И в основном оно направлено
на взаимодействие с
службой поддержки.
Но, что интересно, вот
в системе GeoGuard
она отличается от всех остальных,
потому что она тебя проверяет не
просто, когда ты зашел в момент
критических действий. То есть
критические действия какие у нас есть?
Это логин, это, например,
восстановление пароля,
это
депозит или же
вывод депозита. Вот это критические действия.
Во время всех остальных
действий система антифрода в основном
бездействует, потому что им нет смысла
напрягаться. Но, когда
у тебя запущен GeoGuard,
то он запущен у тебя и активен
все время твоей активности
на компьютере. То есть,
иными словами, он проверяет еще
и твой онлайн. Прикольно,
правда? И
он может заблокировать тебя
в любой момент, если его
машинное обучение или же модели,
которым он научился, будут
выявят в тебе что-то подозрительное.
Поэтому очень часто,
работая с GeoGuard,
существует такая тенденция, что
пользователь
получает одобрение,
создает свой аккаунт, например,
все классно, но потом через некоторое
время он получает бан.
И он не понимает, по какой причине это
произошло. А причин может быть здесь на самом
деле огромное количество. Начиная
от того, что у него прокси мог упасть
и просочиться его реальный
IP-адрес, и заканчивая тем, что
системе кажется, что ты слишком
направлен
на работу с ней.
А вот здесь интересная такая опция есть
хотел бы про нее рассказать.
Дело в том, что
букмекерские компании
они заинтересованы не только
в предоставлении услуг
для того, чтобы получать деньги, но они
заинтересованы в том, чтобы эти деньги сохранить.
А соответственно,
они придумали в данном случае
с GeoGuard бороться с мультиаккаунтингом
следующим образом.
Ведь, казалось бы, можно взять
с этими знаниями, которыми мы обладаем,
поехать в Нью-Джерси,
покупать ноутбуки, выполнять все
что нам необходимо и
фактически жить себе хорошо.
Система так подумала
и сделали они следующее.
Теперь, помимо всего прочего,
необходимо еще
и соблюдать онлайн.
То есть, когда мы устанавливаем,
когда мы заходим на веб-ресурс,
который работает с GeoGuard,
мы загружаем программное обеспечение,
устанавливаем его на наш ПК,
и затем это программное обеспечение
висит у нас в трее.
Работаем мы с веб-ресурсом, не работаем
оно висит в трее.
Да, конечно же, мы можем его закрыть, отключить,
но система
также будет это регистрировать.
И, соответственно, она
задастся вопросом, а почему это
данный человек
использует компьютер
только лишь, когда заходит
на веб-ресурс наш.
Это подозрительно. И, соответственно,
выдаст либо перенаправление,
либо же запретит
данному пользователю
использовать тот или иной
веб-ресурс, например, букмекерскую компанию.
И вот таких вот методик
очень простых, но тем не менее
действенных довольно большое
количество в стеке GeoGuard.
И
популярность данного программного обеспечения
заключается в том, что фактически
очень мало пользователей
в мире могут его
обойти, и обойти самое главное грамотно.
Высокая точность обнаружения,
минимизация ошибок
в блокировках, полный
доступ к системе и
великолепная система идентификации
именно самой машины
в комбинации с адаптивным
обучением угрозам
является действительно
топом на рынке.
Если брать системы
локального антифроида, то есть с помощью
локального программного обеспечения,
то я бы однозначно выделил данную
систему как топовую. Лучше
всех остальных. Потому что даже
тот же XPoint, он, к сожалению,
ну или к счастью нашему, конечно же,
он не дотягивает. Не дотягивает,
дотягивает до функционала Geoguard'а
и, возможно, у них
не слишком развита система машинного
обучения, кто знает.
Но, тем не менее,
такая
такая тенденция есть.
Если брать
WebStack,
то есть именно антифроид
системы, доступные только лишь в браузере,
однозначным лидером я бы, конечно же,
выделил Threat Matrix.
Threat Matrix является топом
именно в деанонимизации пользователей,
хотя вот Akamai наступает ему на
пятки. Ну а
в локальном программном обеспечении равных
Geoguard'у нет.
При проведении реверса
я нашел более
220 параметров,
которые считываются с
ПК-пользователя. И что интересно,
2021 год
мы работали с Geoguard'ом
версии 3.1.13.
2026 год, 5 лет
прошло, мы работаем с версией
3.1.13.
Ни единого обновления за это время.
Классно, правда? А ведь по факту
даже и обновлять нечего. Все информация,
которая считывалась изначально, еще там
5 лет назад, 6 лет назад, она
считывается и сейчас, просто лишь
изменилась методика ее
обработки на стороне бэкэнда.
Невероятно классное решение.
Ну а по факту, если мы возьмем
сейчас все методики, которые
я сегодня вам
рассказал, то Geoguard
использует полностью все, кроме
Akamai
и
Bluetooth. Все остальные
методики используются для
определения геолокации
пользователя. Вот я их выделил
в отдельной схеме.
И конечно же, самыми
сложными методиками для работы,
самыми сложными методиками подмены
являются именно физические.
Физические, такие как
GPS и Wi-Fi триангуляция.
Вот это самые важные,
самые сложные системы для подмены.
Потому что даже тот же самый Bluetooth
подменить, даже если бы его использовали,
подменить по факту это всего-навсего пара
пустяков. Поэтому,
проведя, скажем так,
подведя небольшой
итог,
самыми простыми
методиками, которые не являются
надежными, это методики
геолокации с помощью IP-адреса,
DNS, Traceroute, Windows
Update, Chromecast и
Bluetooth. Элементарно
простые, ничего сложного.
Уже более сложные, но тем не менее
легко поддающиеся
все равно к подмене, если о них знать,
это системы Interface Ping и
Akamai PingPong.
Всего-навсего один сервер в США
решает полностью
весь этот стек проблем.
Ну и высокая сложность подмены
это GPS,
Wi-Fi триангуляция и
полный комплекс методик
GeoGuard. Давайте мы сейчас
рассмотрим, каким образом
есть возможность подменить
использование Wi-Fi сети,
потому что, как я и говорил
в начале нашего вебинара, мы по каждому
из пунктов прошлись, как подменить,
надо, соответственно, то же самое
сообщить еще и по
Wi-Fi.
Сразу скажу, что следующие
фотографии являются
нереальными,
они нарисованы нейросетью,
но в их основе абсолютно
реальные кейсы, которые были
придуманы некоторыми пользователями
и давайте
их рассмотрим.
Подмена Wi-Fi,
подмена Wi-Fi триангуляции, Wi-Fi данных
может строиться на абсолютно
различных методиках. Самая
простая, самая, я бы сказал,
наверное, первая методика, которая
появилась, это
роутеры Mikrotik.
Почему именно Mikrotik? Потому что
самая дешевая модель роутера позволяет
изменить MAC-адрес
беспроводной сети. И даже
в далеком 2021 году
я тоже пользователям советовал
использовать Mikrotik
для того, чтобы эмулировать
окружающие Wi-Fi сети.
Так вот, роутеры
Mikrotik, каждый из них будет
представлять из себя
внешнюю Wi-Fi сеть.
А данные тогда, на тот момент,
на момент 2021 года, мы брали
в открытом источнике Wiggle.net,
но после жалобы компании
Geocomply они закрыли
доступ к источникам даже
для незарегистрированных пользователей.
Таким образом, хотели побороться.
Но у них ничего не вышло.
Как, впрочем, и у нас затем,
через полгода.
Так вот, когда мы
имеем у себя
арсенал из роутеров,
каждый из которых является источником сигнала,
то есть проблема.
Проблема заключается в том, что
урбанизация нашей планеты идет
невероятными темпами. И, к сожалению,
мы в большинстве своем
находимся в мегаполисах,
в которых есть огромное количество
окружающих Wi-Fi сигналов.
И какая-то
светлая голова придумала,
что необходимо использовать
так называемый Jammer.
Jammer, то есть глушилка по-простому,
которая позволит
заглушить окружающие
Wi-Fi сети, но благодаря тому,
что роутеры наши эмулируемые
будут находиться близко к источнику
принятия сигнала,
то есть роутеры раздают сигнал,
а источник принятия сигнала
Wi-Fi свисток, условно говоря.
Здесь он изображен посредине,
вот эта коробка.
На них Jammer не будет действовать,
его силы не хватит, а, соответственно,
внешние сети будут заглушены.
Ну, методика,
скажем так, так себе, скажу.
Почему? Потому что, во-первых,
очень неудобно, конечно же, менять
постоянно вручную информацию
о Wi-Fi сетях в этом роутере,
в этих роутерах,
находить ее, коррелировать,
опять же. Но и
Wi-Fi Jammer очень часто
любят отключаться и
дают определенный сбой.
Сбой какого рода?
Такого, что может просочиться
какая-то внешняя сеть.
И, соответственно, ваша любимая
вьетнамская сеть, к которой вы подключаетесь,
или сеть вашего соседа,
который максимально увеличил
ее мощность для того, чтобы
у него даже в гараже порнхаб ловил,
может сделать вам
очень большую проблему,
и ваш аккаунт попадет в бан.
Ну, а также еще, помимо всего прочего,
пользователи очень часто забывают,
что кроме видимых сетей,
есть еще скрытые сети,
у которых тоже может быть сильный сигнал,
и то, что вы не видите этих сетей
в своем окошке Windows
для подключения, абсолютно не
означает, что этих сетей нет.
И, в частности, также здесь хотелось бы
еще отметить такой важный момент.
Дело в том, что
если пользователь не живет
в каком-то крупном мегаполисе,
он может подумать, что
отключив Wi-Fi просто у себя дома,
все будет классно.
Но, по факту,
операционная система Windows
видит намного больше Wi-Fi сетей,
чем видите вы.
И она показывает вам лишь те сети,
к которым возможно подключение.
А по факту,
у вас, условно говоря, есть 5 сетей,
к которым вы можете подключиться
по решению операционной системы Windows.
А еще, помимо этого,
у вас есть, например, 15 сетей,
сигнал которых очень слабый,
но тем не менее регистрируется
вашим Wi-Fi адаптером.
Но Windows считает, что показывать их вам
нет смысла, потому что вы все равно
к ним не подключитесь.
Поэтому изоляция всего-навсего видимых сетей
не решает этого вопроса.
И для этого придумали вот такую
простейшую схему.
Но схема не очень хорошая.
Почему?
Потому что в данном случае,
помимо неудобства работы,
вы еще и получаете следующее.
Ваши все Wi-Fi роутеры
находятся рядом
с приемником.
Такого в реальности быть не может.
Никаким образом.
Соответственно, в обычной нашей жизни
роутеры окружают нас на расстоянии
нескольких метров
или нескольких десятков метров.
За счет этого и происходит
процедура триангуляции.
А если эти все роутеры
будут находиться в одной точке,
то это уже аномалия.
Такого быть в реальности не может.
И эту схему пытались
видоизменить.
Я покажу, каким образом
мы пытались эту схему видоизменить.
Для того, чтобы
не работать с роутерами
и более как-то
централизированно управлять,
использовали так называемую
плату ESP32.
Вот она находится на данной
картинке слева.
Плата ESP32
позволяла создавать,
если не ошибаюсь,
до 64 сетей.
То есть производить транслирование
этих сетей и подменять
расходы.
В принципе, все классно,
все хорошо.
Плюс ко всему, можно было
даже отказаться от джаммера
и отказаться
в пользу, например,
какого-нибудь Wi-Fi адаптера,
у которого открутить антенну.
По факту схема полный кал
и работала крайне нестабильно.
И ни одного решения, которое
более-менее нормально бы
смогло работать с этой схемой,
поскольку все равно
даже с открученной антенной
можно работать только лишь,
если знаешь один интересный лайфхак.
Но люди не все об этом знали,
поэтому придумали вот такую
вот хрень.
Хрень под названием
коробка Фарадея.
Вообще, производная от клетки Фарадея,
но, тем не менее, это конкретно
может быть гроб Фарадея,
корыта Фарадея.
Короче, какая-нибудь херня
со словом Фарадей.
Кстати, кто не знает,
Фарадей это у нас известнейший
физик, если не ошибаюсь, английский.
Или австралийский.
Ну, не суть важна.
Так вот, суть заключалась в том,
чтобы убрать окружающие
Wi-Fi сигналы,
благодаря изоляции приемников
и передатчиков
в одной единой области.
То есть в области, например,
клетки Фарадея.
Клетка Фарадея это экранирующий элемент,
который не позволяет сигналам
не выходить, соответственно, наружу.
Но
для создания клетки Фарадея
можно применять огромное количество
различных методик и
суть их одна, просто разные материалы.
Краска Фарадея,
обои Фарадея,
ткань Фарадея,
сетка Фарадея,
различного рода экранирующие элементы.
Так вот,
здесь вроде бы
все нормально и на практике
действительно можно реализовать
такую схему, но
есть несколько но.
Первое но, о котором пользователи,
которые не учили физику в школе,
забывают, что данную коробку
необходимо также еще и заземлить,
иначе ни черта это работать не будет.
Но, помимо всего прочего, самой
большой проблемой заключалась как раз
проблема в том, что
все источники
передачи сигнала
будут находиться на расстоянии
нескольких сантиметров от источника
сигнала, что опять же
по факту невозможно
в реальных условиях,
потому что, как я говорил ранее,
несколько десятков метров
должно быть между устройствами
для того, чтобы правильно
эмулировать силу сигнала.
А иначе
у нас получаются идеальные лабораторные
условия.
Но есть еще несколько интересных
вариантов. Вот эту коробку
Фарадея можно было элементарно
простым образом заменить всего на
один Wi-Fi свисток.
Условно говоря, тот же TP-Link,
как я нарисовал здесь.
У этого TP-Link откручивается антенна,
а дальше TP-Link подключается
в правильный,
мощный USB
джаммер.
Что такое диммер, прошу прощения?
Не джаммер, а диммер.
Диммер позволяет регулировать
напряжение.
И таким образом,
чем меньше напряжение
вы будете подавать на ваш
Wi-Fi свисток,
тем меньшее количество сетей
он будет обнаруживать.
И фактически,
благодаря этой простейшей методике
вам нахер никакая клетка не нужна,
ни коробка,
ничего остального.
Всего-навсего нужен правильный диммер,
который из-за того, что будет расти
сила сопротивления, не будет перегреваться.
И таким образом
можно сократить
радиус обнаружения Wi-Fi сетей
всего-навсего до 1 метра.
Это конкретно то, что проверено на практике.
Повторюсь, фотографии
сгенерированы нейросетью
Nanobanano, но суть
фактически одна и та же.
Но есть еще
очень-очень-очень
плохой момент, опять же,
в данной системе.
И заключается этот плохой момент в том,
что опять
приходим к лабораторным условиям.
И в этих лабораторных
условиях всегда будет видно то,
что сила сигнала
не соответствует
тому, что может быть
на практике.
То есть все сети находятся
в одной точке.
Фактически так оно и происходит.
Поэтому,
какие еще есть варианты?
Расскажу еще один довольно интересный вариант.
Это вариант, когда
это тоже люди реализовывали
на практике, это так уже
истории, скажем так, рассказываем.
USB over Ethernet
или USB over IP.
Люди, которые решили
быть очень предприимчивыми,
они платили
своим знакомым,
знакомых знакомых, которые находятся
в Нью-Джерси, для того, чтобы
те покупали
Wi-Fi-свистки и
вставляли их в свои ПК, когда
запускали вот это программное обеспечение
под названием Kernel Pro.
И таким образом
можно было получить
Wi-Fi сети из Нью-Джерси,
когда ты находишься в каком-нибудь,
например, Биробиджане.
И ты действительно, благодаря этому
программному обеспечению, ты видишь эти
Wi-Fi сети, с небольшим шаманизмом, конечно,
но, тем не менее, видишь.
Но все эти методики,
абсолютно все эти методики, они
потерпели крах.
Потерпели крах они
по нескольким причинам.
Причина номер один, про которую
я говорил уже заранее,
это
лабораторные условия и практически
они отличаются.
То есть то, что вы можете
подменить геолокацию, например,
и какое-нибудь программное обеспечение
покажет, что действительно вы находитесь
в Нью-Джерси, абсолютно не лишает
вас сетевых аномалий,
к которым будет очень претензионно
относиться тот же самый Geocomply.
Поэтому, поместив
все устройства
передачи информации
и источник получения этой информации
в какую-то изолированную область,
в лабораторных условиях
это сработает. Но не будет
работать против того же самого
GeoGuard, поскольку в реальной среде
вокруг нас
роутеры расположены на расстоянии
нескольких десятков метров.
Плюс, вы включили, например,
AirDrop на телефоне, включаете
когда-нибудь, ну или что-нибудь подобного плана,
у вас появляется
скрытая Wi-Fi сеть.
Вы подключаетесь к своему
телевизору, в некоторых
случаях в телевизорах тот же самый
Wi-Fi вы можете подключиться, к вашему
холодильнику. Ваш сосед,
включает какую-нибудь информацию,
например. Либо же просто упала
сила сигнала, даже потому, что просто
кто-то прошел рядом.
В вариации есть огромное количество
и всегда радиосреда
она не является статичной
в реальной жизни. То есть она постоянно
меняется. И сила сигнала, даже до вашего
домашнего роутера, она может
меняться тысячу, десять тысяч, сто тысяч
раз в течение одного
рабочего дня. Соответственно, при
считывании данной информации
на протяжении
очень даже короткого периода
времени, на протяжении всего-навсего
десяти-двадцати минут, есть
возможность получить информацию
о том, что сети являются абсолютно
стабильными. А соответственно,
имеет место быть либо эмуляция,
либо же все они находятся
в одной точке и таким образом
используется какая-либо
система подмены
геолокации. Поэтому использование
вот таких вот материалов, оно
конечно хорошо, но опять же повторюсь
только лишь в лабораторных условиях.
А в реальных условиях необходимо
было бы сделать не клетку
Фарадея, а необходимо было бы сделать
что-нибудь по типу квартиры
Фарадея, где роутеры
нужно было бы разнести
по разным комнатам
и затем экранировать
всю квартиру, чтобы не было возможности
поймать
какие-либо еще окружающие
Wi-Fi сети. Но вот в такой системе
еще более-менее может быть
что-нибудь бы каким-либо образом
сработало. Но по факту,
кроме как
скажем, заявление о том, что все
работает, увы,
никаких методик
обнаружено, ну лично мной не было.
По факту я выделил бы
всего-навсего несколько
на данный момент
методик, с помощью которых можно
подменить геолокацию
и подменить ее правильно.
Первая методика довольно простая.
Это методика хуков.
Дело в том, что GeoGuard
будет обращаться к
окружающим Wi-Fi сетям
с помощью так называемого
Windows WLAN API.
И ответ можно пропустить,
а вот запрос, точнее
запрос можно пропустить,
а вот ответ от WLAN API
можно видоизменить
с помощью Windows Hooks.
Благо у нас существуют сейчас
нейросети, которые позволяют написать
Windows Hooks, особенно DeepSeq,
без каких-либо проблем.
Вторая методика, которой можно
воспользоваться, это
измененные
устройства.
Большинство устройств, точнее
не большинство, а множество устройств
имеет свой открытый исходный
код, утекший на просторы интернета.
И, соответственно,
путем нехитрых видоизменений
можно заставить эти же
устройства работать немного по-другому.
Но либо же третий вариант, который
реализовал в софте у себя я,
это полностью новое
устройство, которое позволяет
делать то, что я ему
скажу. Метод самый сложный
из всех, поскольку требует написания
полного стека, то есть самого
виртуального устройства,
плюс драйвера к нему,
и плюс еще так же сделать, чтобы
это все работало правильно.
А почему это должно работать правильно,
я вам сейчас расскажу. В противном случае
единственным физическим методом
это является квартира Faraday,
которую вы можете увидеть сейчас на своих
экранах. Но даже несмотря
на то, что вы можете построить себе
такую квартиру Faraday,
есть еще одна вещь,
как говорил Стив Джобс,
которая не позволит вам
нормально работать.
Вот она.
Это так называемые
Multi-ID
идентификация
в GeoGuard.
Что это означает?
Если бы программное обеспечение
GeoGuard всего-навсего устанавливалось
на ваш ПК для того, чтобы проверить
геолокацию, мы бы лишились огромного
количества проблем, с которыми
пользователи сталкиваются ежедневно.
А по факту, если сделать
реверс клиента от
GeoGuard, мы можем
увидеть, что
вся информация о нашем железе
считывается и формируется
в один единый ID.
Вся информация о драйверах,
для того, чтобы не было каких-либо
фейковых драйверов, либо же драйверов
типа Hook, про которые я говорил ранее,
вся информация о драйверах
считывается и формируется
в ID. Операционная система
формируется
в несколько идентификаторов,
в частности, конкретные данные
о телеметрии, которые
созданы самой операционной системой
Windows, плюс
идентификаторы
нашего пользователя,
плюс идентификаторы конкретно
установленной операционной системы.
Также формируются в один единый ID.
Плюс установленное
программное обеспечение, которое проверяется
на предмет каких-либо вредоносов,
чего-либо аномального,
поскольку кейсы могут рассматриваться
затем, также формируется
в единый ID. И, казалось бы,
можно всего-навсего переустановить,
добавить какую-нибудь программу,
либо же видоизменить
с помощью
CC Tools какой-нибудь ID
в Windows, и все поменяется, но на самом
деле нет. Дело в том, что
в
GeoGuard реализована
так называемая процедура в фазе хеширования.
Процедура в фазе хеширования
позволяет игнорировать
до 30%
измененной информации.
Но в таком стеке, который
состоит из четырех основных
групп, идентификаторов,
игнорирование даже
30% информации все равно является
скажем так, ключом к победе,
поскольку оно позволяет идентифицировать
пользователя полностью.
Добавим к этому еще
некоторые моменты.
Недавно мы с вами изучили, что такое
TPM-чип.
Соответственно, данные с TPM-чипа,
наличие Secure Boot обязательно,
наличие
самого TPM-чипа обязательно,
сертификация TPM-чипа
обязательно, то есть все, что можно
взять с TPM,
также используется GeoGuard.
Информация о том,
используется ли виртуальная машина
плюс методики определения виртуальной
машины, также используется
GeoGuard. Ну и конечно же
то, что мы говорили с вами
по поводу вот этих вот
методик, да,
не всегда является рабочим,
потому что, если вы используете, например,
это на ноутбуке и захотели
себе, например,
реализовать следующую схему,
взять огромное количество старых
ноутбуков, огромное количество Wi-Fi
свистков и использовать
один ноутбук, один аккаунт,
то у вас, к сожалению, так же
не получится. Почему? Потому что система
запрещает нормально работать,
если у вас есть встроенный
Wi-Fi модуль, то система
считает, что использовать внешний Wi-Fi модуль
для вас является
нецелесообразным, является
аномалией. И таким образом
она захочет
убрать данное
устройство для того, чтобы вы
использовали реальный Wi-Fi модуль. А там у вас
уже, увы, изменять
вольтаж будет крайне сложно
и, соответственно, вы будете все равно
видеть окружающие вас Wi-Fi
сети. Поэтому на
текущий момент есть
всего-навсего несколько вариантов,
когда можно
работать с этой сетью
правильно.
И, в частности,
один из самых простых
вариантов, самых простых,
я сейчас напишу его
в чат,
а затем расскажу, почему
я не сделал
для него
отдельного слайда. Потому что, возможно,
вот эта информация сейчас
не попадет в
YouTube.
Ну, кто пришел
на вебинар, тот пришел.
Что такое Infinix?
Infinix это
мобильный телефон. Этот мобильный
телефон не так прост.
Я хочу рассказать сейчас вам историю.
История
заключается о том,
давайте представим себе, это сказка от
Vector T13.
Сказка от Vector T13 заключается
в том, что
определенная группа людей
на определенной административной территории
по предварительному сговору
решила
осуществлять
распространение
скажем так,
как сказать по-простому?
Барыжить решила.
Распространение наркотических веществ.
Так вот,
для того, чтобы быть
охрененно анонимными,
эта группа людей была очень умна.
И они зашли на небесный
форум в сети интернет,
где они приобрели
телефоны с
сменой имей.
Представьте себе, хитрые поцы.
Вот только лишь
одна
проблема заключалась
в этих телефонах.
Когда они нажимали на телефончиках своих
звездочка 06 и шотка,
их имей менялся.
Действительно, да, там постоянно был
новый имей. Классно.
Очень продвинутые телефоны.
Если запустишь какое-нибудь приложение,
которое позволяет получить информацию
о твоем идентификаторе
радиочастотного модуля,
тоже там все менялось.
Просто красота, согласитесь.
Но мы сейчас
пристанем именно к имей,
потому что именно телефоны со сменой имей
наиболее популярны сейчас
в сети интернет, правда?
Если ты хочешь быть анонимным
и тебе нужен телефон.
Так вот, какое бы приложение
купленных аж за
тысячу долларов в телефонах
всегда показывало, что функционал
по смене имей работал.
Но проблема заключалась
в том, что
человек, который продавал эти телефоны
со сменой имей,
был либо альтернативно гениален,
либо же ему было просто-напросто
похуй. Я думаю,
что были оба варианта.
Дело в том, что
в телефонах имей
вся остальная идентифицирующая
телефонная информация
находится в так называемом
модуле NVRAM
энергонезависимой области.
И
программные обеспечения типа
Xposit или же подобные ему
производят
всего-навсего перехват запросов.
То есть, иными словами,
когда программное обеспечение
либо же сервис
проводит запрос к NVRAM
для того, чтобы узнать
имей,
то модуль Xposit, например,
он просто подменяет эти данные.
Но что же, блять, происходит,
когда используется реальный сигнал
сотовой связи?
А не происходит ровным счетом ни хера.
Потому что модуль
Xposit ни хера не работает
в этот момент. И, соответственно,
то, что человечек видел, что у него меняется
на его телефоне,
ни хрена не менялось
в сотовой сети. Вот такая
вот интересная история. Как, собственно,
говоря, трахали, трахают
и будут трахать спецслужбы
всех анонимусов, у которых
есть одна лишняя хромосома.
Так что не забывайте об этом.
Если телефон реально меняет имей,
можно это проверить только лишь с помощью
MCI-кетчера,
либо же с помощью HackRF, BladeRF.
Так вот, к чему это все я говорил.
Есть такая модель
телефонов, точнее, марка телефонов
под названием Infinix.
Великолепные
девайсы, которые позволяют изменить
всю информацию
о себе, причем абсолютно штатными
методами. Так что я бы рекомендовал,
если мы разбираем
физический метод изменения для того, чтобы
была возможность подменить
идентификатор
самого устройства и так далее,
я бы рекомендовал пользователям обратить внимание
непосредственно на марку
телефонов Infinix.
Из физических решений
на текущий момент это
в плане телефонов,
наверное, единственное.
Задание ноутбуков тоже важно.
Есть ноутбуки
вот такой вот марки.
Марки Framework.
Также
отлично подходят для работы
с GeoGuard,
поскольку позволяют изменить
аппаратную часть без
изменения самого устройства.
Но, конечно же, придется заморачиваться
с установкой операционной
системы и всего прочего.
Но, увы, от этого никуда
не денешься. Что, кстати, тоже в
телефонах Infinix необходимо будет делать,
но в Android делать это намного проще.
Причем все штатные методы,
они очень хорошо автоматизируются
для того, чтобы изменение всех
идентификаторов и переустановка
операционной системы проходила всего-навсего
в одно нажатие клавиши
либо же в один клик мышкой на,
собственно говоря, основном ПК.
Но, опять же, это устройство,
с которым можно работать.
Что с окружающими Wi-Fi сигналами?
С окружающими Wi-Fi сигналами
вам необходимо использовать
ту же самую квартиру Faraday,
про которую я говорил. Поскольку,
если вы живете в мегаполисе, это ваш единственный
вариант. Ну, либо же брать
охапку роутеров, брать ваш
фреймворк ноутбук, либо же
мобильное устройство
и выезжать куда-нибудь на природу,
провести время с пользой и
также, соответственно, поработать.
Ну, это как
такие варианты. Если вы знаете
какие-либо еще альтернативные версии,
вы можете
поделиться в комментариях под данным
видео, поскольку я подозреваю,
что я очень много
различного рода изобретений
и ноу-хау узнаю из
комментариев к данному видео на
YouTube.
В свою очередь, я
попытался реализовать
полный стэк,
то есть и подмену Wi-Fi,
и подмену, соответственно,
всех идентификаторов операционной
системы, которая уже давно реализована.
И, если вы обратили внимание,
это еще и защита от детектора
виртуальных машин, которая сейчас
проходит все тесты, не существует
теста на текущий момент публичного,
по крайней мере, которое бы она не прошла.
Ну, а как система эта
покажет себя на практике, вы узнаете
из отзывов других пользователей, которые
уже ее будут использовать,
начиная с текущего
понедельника. Большое спасибо
за внимание. С вами был VectorT13,
а теперь мы переходим
к ответам на ваши вопросы,
которые вы могли задать
в начале нашего вебинара,
а также в процессе данного вебинара.
Но наш вебинар
на текущий момент уже на 5 минут
превысил
запланированный тайминг,
так что прошу прощения
на все вопросы, а их уже
167. На все вопросы
я ответить, к сожалению, не смогу, но
постараюсь по максимуму.
Так что,
начинаем. Итак,
переходим к вопросам.
Где наши вопросы? Так, первый вопрос
от пользователя
Ванко.
Здравствуйте, Дмитрий.
Здравствуйте, Ванко.
Надеюсь, у вас будут замечательные
выходные.
Я бы тоже надеялся на это, Ванко.
Мой прекрасный, замечательный
субботний вечер я провожу
в компании великолепных людей,
которые пришли послушать мой вебинар,
и это уже придает мне мотивацию
и силы делать еще более интересные
продукты, и с удовольствием
я с ними болтаю. Так что мои выходные,
можно сказать, великолепны.
Я настроил геолокацию
с предустановленным Amazon
и параметр обхода и обнаружения
виртуальных машин в персональной версии.
Прокси использует
IPv6, как вы и сказали.
Но оценка ReCAPTCHA 3
составляет всего 0.1.
0.1, просто 0.1.
Как вы думаете, это как-то
влияет на систему защиты
от мошенничества или что-то еще?
Потому что новый аккаунт Amazon был
блокирован очень быстро.
Спасибо за отличный вебинар сегодня.
Я не могу сказать вам, к сожалению, заранее.
Почему? Потому что
у меня, к сожалению, очень мало данных.
Прокси использует IPv6.
В данном случае меня вызывает
наибольшее количество вопросов.
То есть есть на рынке
как бы прокси,
которые просто показывают, что у тебя есть
IPv6, а есть, которые позволяют
через них полностью, полноценно работать.
Какие у вас и также
кто является источником данных прокси?
Потому что не забывайте
об одном очень важном
методе мошенничества.
Если вы арендуете ВПС
с IPv6, просто
какого-нибудь хостинга,
вы можете, в принципе, эту ВПС
масштабировать таким образом, что у вас будет
огромное количество этих
IPv6 прокси, которые вы можете
продавать. И, соответственно,
если в данном случае у вас
имела место быть именно такая
система продажи, то, к сожалению,
это явный бот
паттерн. Так что рекомендую обратить
внимание на это. Но, к сожалению, повторюсь,
больше из вашего
сообщения, увы, не могу
ничего извлечь
более детального.
Но также еще,
когда вы работаете с
reCAPTCHA 3, обратите, пожалуйста,
внимание на
сам браузер. И еще
маленькая рекомендация.
Ну так, чисто ради эксперимента.
Несмотря на то,
что используется система Bits,
для загрузки браузера Chrome,
все-таки рекомендую
попытаться установить,
загрузить его и установить вручную
через Edge.
Ну, есть определенного рода
подозрения, скажем так.
Идем дальше. Идем дальше.
Следующий вопрос. Это вопрос от пользователя
Milky Way. Виктор, добрый день. Добрый день,
Milky Way. Поскольку ты упоминал
Arch Linux как лучшую систему для
анонимизации, вопрос. Является
ли система инициализации
систем D проблемным компонентом для
обеспечения анонимности?
Смущает компонент систем D Resolvet,
который имеет список откатных
DNS серверов по умолчанию.
Насколько,
по твоему мнению,
имеет смысл использовать более
простой OpenRC?
Уважаемый Milky Way, вы можете
использовать абсолютно все, что угодно.
Arch Linux был мной упомянут
только лишь поскольку
его архаичность
именно. Просто его простая
архаичность. Там нет особо ничего
лишнего. А касаемо систем D,
то, что вас смутило. Безусловно,
разработчики данной системы не
ставили себе за задачу сделать
систему абсолютно анонимной.
Они сделали ее,
скажем так, универсальной. Это фундамент.
И в любом случае, какую
бы систему вы не взяли,
ну я не знаю, ну кроме, конечно, Tails
и Hoonix, про которые я сегодня уже
упоминал. Я не знаю систему, где
у вас уже будет сразу предустановлена
какая-то анонимная сеть.
Это как бы само собой разумеющее
что, если вы купили машину,
вам необходимо
уметь на ней ездить
и как минимум заправлять ее.
Именно такую аналогию я бы привел
к сетевой настройке системы.
Далее. Вопрос от пользователя
Milky Way. В чем был
подвох вопросов в антидетекте на
должность саппорта?
Подвоха не было никакого.
Там просто
были вопросы, которые связаны с
историей и психологией.
Меня
можно найти огромное
количество. Я по жизни огромное
количество людей встречал, которые
являются
технически очень подкованными,
но являются
абсолютными или
назвать так сложно, интровертами
или
нелюдимыми,
скажем так. И несмотря на то, что
человек может быть семи пядей во лбу,
из него как саппорт может быть
абсолютно полный ноль.
И в то же время, если человек
не проявляет каких-то
амбиций, например, я скажу
честно, что вот
зарплаты, когда человек
там первый вопрос был по поводу
сколько вам хватает на жизнь, но если человеку
хватает на жизнь в месяц тысячи
долларов, ну простите,
нам не о чем. Наши пути
точно вместе не сойдутся.
Ну а так было просто
несколько вопросов, не то чтобы с подвохом,
а в первую очередь
я этот тест создавал
для того, чтобы его нельзя было пройти
с помощью нейросети.
Вот собственно говоря и все.
А подвоха никакого не было.
Дальше, следующий вопрос
от пользователя Milky Way. Вот пользователь
Milky Way замечательно подготовился к данному
вебинару, что и вам советую в следующий
раз. Сможет ли
в будущем веб-ресурс,
который сотрудничает с Palantir
видеть примерный
маршрут от исходного IP?
То, что вы сейчас говорите, было
реализовано уже до
Palantir.
Объясню, где это было.
Первая система глобального
мониторинга IP, которая была
на основе мониторинга
скажите мне
магистральных интернет
провайдеров, она всем известна,
называлась она PRISM.
Вторая система
после того, как PRISM
признали негодной, вторая система
которая существует на текущий момент
до сих пор, это система
от ANB
под названием Treasure Map
или карта сокровищ. Можете
найти о ней информацию,
но только не ищите через
нейросети,
они вам ни черта об этом не дадут.
Через Google не ищите тоже,
потому что Google вам не даст
информацию, тем более он сейчас не дает
информацию
даже десятилетней
давности. А информация
в данной сети Treasure Map как раз
появилась где-то в районе
2013-2014 года.
Поэтому рекомендую использовать
Shodan, либо же можете
найти на форумах
шифропанков, очень много информации
об этом.
Так что да, да, я уверен, что сейчас
от самой
компании Palantir такие продукты
уже существуют.
Дальше
следующий вопрос, вопрос
для Milky Way. Виктор, я правильно понимаю,
что метрики производительности CPU,
RAM и SSD дают
просто уникальнейший идентификатор
устройства и любой веб-ресурс JavaScript
может определить, что два разных
IP это одно и то же устройство?
Практически верно.
Практически верно, за исключением только
лишь унифицированных устройств, таких
как, например, серия ноутбуков
имеет одно и то же,
одни и те же параметры
производительности, например.
И, соответственно, да,
но,
прошу прощения,
уже немного устал.
Соответственно, да, конечно же, можно
выделить и уникализировать устройство,
но, помимо всего прочего, нужно понимать,
что еще и пользовательский
экспириенс дает,
скажем так,
нагрузку на производительность.
Поэтому
на коротком промежутке времени
100%,
ну, не 100%, давайте 99%.
Что я имею в виду?
Если мы будем пытаться
отслеживать одно и то же устройство
по меркам производительности,
по метрикам производительности
на протяжении, например, месяца,
будет слишком большая вариативность.
А если мы, например, будем рассматривать
на примере суток,
то, безусловно, выделить конкретное устройство
можно без особого труда.
Следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя Milky Way.
Почему One Plus 7 Pro
подходит для полнодискового шифрования?
В чем особенность этой модели,
почему One Plus 7T?
Вот эту информацию я раскрывать
не хочу. Я обычно отвечаю
на все вопросы, но
просто хочу ее сохранить для самого себя.
Скажем так,
вам могу сказать,
я сегодня об этом уже упоминал,
то есть связано это все с NVRAM.
Вроде бы один и тот же телефон, одна и та же модель,
просто лишь индексом отличается.
Но вот, кстати, еще,
если хотите более детально,
я вам покажу.
NetHunter.
Релиз Kali Linux для мобильных устройств.
Почему NetHunter есть для
One Plus 7 Pro
и нет для One Plus 7T?
Можете погуглить.
Дальше. Следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя Richter.
Дмитрий, приветствую. Приветствую, Richter.
Во-первых, благодарю за вебинары.
Три последних вебинара просто охеренные.
Я очень рад, Richter, что вам понравилось,
потому что месяц выдался
очень продуктивным.
У нас три вебинара прошло
на протяжении месяца, и вебинары большие.
На прошлый вебинар я создал
около 90 слайдов,
92 слайда, по-моему.
Ну, конечно же, нужно понимать, что
моя загруженность
10 лет назад и загруженность сейчас
очень разные.
И поэтому, благодаря тому,
что появилось отличное средство
автоматизации слайдов,
у меня есть возможность тратить
не 3-4 дня, как ранее,
а тратить всего-навсего один день
для того, чтобы подготовить вебинар.
И я думаю, что пользователям,
если будут нравиться мои вебинары,
текущие в новом формате,
я буду проводить их чаще.
Пожалуйста, не игнорируйте вопрос.
У вас в Telegram-профиле
есть сторис. Жизнь у вас красивая,
конечно, но вот один из постов
меня не на шутку заинтересовал.
Оказывается, вы были в золотом треугольнике
в начале 2025 года.
В конце 2025 года на YouTube появилось очень много
видео о скам-фермах из того района.
Я посмотрел и не нашел
ни одного нормального отеля там.
Соответственно, вариант, чтобы отдыхать...
В общем,
Рихтер, я бы сказал так,
что
то, что сейчас муссируется в YouTube,
оно не имеет
отношения к реальности
даже на половину.
Я бы сказал так, может быть,
30% реальности есть.
Вот эти все якобы
жертвы, которые потом дают
интервью и рассказывают ой-ой-ой,
но
как бы
выражаясь по-другому, не все так
однозначно.
И касаемо того,
был ли я там или не был,
да, действительно, я присутствовал там,
но я присутствовал в другой части,
я присутствовал
на встрече в Лаосе.
Эта встреча была по продаже
моего бизнеса
прошлого по
линию карт банковских.
И с Confirm
я не имею там никакого
отношения.
Идем дальше. Следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя Виктор Дудко.
Здравствуйте, уважаемый Дмитрий.
Здравствуйте, уважаемый Виктор Дудко.
Может ли сайт сканировать Wi-Fi точки поблизости
и как лучше просканировать
виртуальную машину?
Какой самый оптимальный способ для работы
с банками? Подойдет ли JetLine router
или стоит присмотреться к GeoBox?
По поводу того,
может ли веб-сайт
сканировать
окружающие Wi-Fi сети?
Ответ и да, и нет.
Почему? Потому что есть в браузерах
так называемый GeoLocation API,
который как раз базируется на
метриках GPS и метриках Wi-Fi.
Поэтому здесь
ответ да.
Получить информацию о конкретных
сетях на текущий
момент, насколько я помню, невозможно.
Вот здесь, если честно, я вам сейчас
врать не буду. Может быть
пользователи напишут в комментариях,
но
я, честно говоря, не встречал кода,
который может показать
окружающие меня Wi-Fi сети.
Кода для...
Извините, может быть ошибаюсь.
Я уже немного подустал,
поэтому sorry.
Какой самый оптимальный способ
для работы с банками?
Подойдет ли
JetLine router или стоит присмотреться
к GeoBox?
GeoBox являются топовыми
продуктами. Оба из этих продуктов
являются
действительно высококачественным
программным обеспечением.
Поэтому
возможно в каком-то из продуктов
вам больше понравится служба
поддержки. Возможно в каком-то из продуктов
вам больше понравится интерфейс.
Я рекомендую присмотреться
к обоим продуктам и, честно говоря,
выделить лидера среди них
очень сложно. Оба продукта являются
высокопрофессиональными и
высокотехнологичными
программным обеспечением.
Я понял,
чего мне так тяжело.
Я последнюю неделю не спал
больше четырех часов.
Вот почему этот, наверное, первый
вебинар, который меня немного
вымотал. Итак,
следующий вопрос от Виктора Дудко
я ответил.
Дальше, следующий вопрос.
Как...
У пользователя пять глаз.
Как на андроиде от Geoguard узнать
свое местоположение и какие-то другие
полезные геоданные? Какие приложения
или методы существуют для тестирования
Geoguard на андроиде без
заключения договоров с Geocomply?
Вы можете сделать
следующим образом. Очень
просто. Взять
чат жопоты,
взять документацию
о Google Geolocation API
и попросить чат
жопоты, чтобы он вам составил маленький
АПК. И, соответственно,
установить этот АПК себе на андроид.
Других методик я на текущий
момент, увы, не знаю.
Но вот эта методика самая простая.
Даже без знаний программирования вы сможете
написать такое программное обеспечение
всего-навсего за один вечер.
Ну, либо же обратитесь к какому-нибудь
профессионалу, он вам
напишет то же самое за
час, может быть.
Вот. Это единственный
способ.
По поводу
Mid-Device Integrity,
Mid-Strong Integrity
используйте
телефон марки
Infinix. Есть, конечно, еще
там, например, Pine 3
телефоны. Вообще,
в принципе, телефонов, которые позволяют
полностью себя видоизменять,
их очень большое количество различных
марок. Но я среди
всех, которые пробовал, я все-таки
отдаю предпочтение, безусловно,
Infinix. Ну и, опять же, нужно
понимать, что цена на них копейки.
Вы за 100 долларов можете взять себе этот
телефон и просто возьмите,
поиграйтесь, попробуйте.
Они продаются везде.
Ну, это вообще не проблема их найти. Это
не какой-то эксклюзивный товар. Это просто
китаец с
хорошим кодом.
Далее.
Вопрос от
пользователя Кирилл. Огромные
вопросы. Привет, Вектор. Привет,
Кирилл. Не знаю, можно ли задавать
столько вопросов. Можно задавать свои
несколько вопросов. Но буду благодарен,
если понятно и кратко ответишь. У меня их
13. Вот пользователь
Milky Way и пользователь Кирилл великолепно
подготовились и задали вопросы
в правильный тайминг.
Итак, начинаем. На одном из
вопросов, первый. На одном из прошлых
вебинаров ты говорил, что маки до
2017 года подходят для анонимизации
или в качестве антидетектора для обхода
антифронт систем. Почему именно до 2017
года? Какие отличия есть после
2017 года? До 2017
года Apple
Silicon позволяет себя видоизменять.
Вот что можно сделать.
И, соответственно, если мы рассматриваем
их в качестве антидетектора,
то модифицированный
EFI загрузчик, который позволит вам
изменять всю информацию о вашем
ПК, может вам помочь
в изменении и идентификаторов
Apple Silicon. То есть,
иными словами, это аналог TPM
чипов в Apple устройствах.
На последующих моделях это сделать
невозможно.
Это только на
iOS можно сделать или на других
OS тоже.
Не знаю, при чем тут iOS, извините,
не понял. System76
не на Windows тоже, но
на System76 можно поставить
все, что угодно.
Вопрос второй. Подходит ли
процедура генерализации Windows
как антидетект лучше или
если нет, то почему?
Генерализация может подойти для
локального программного обеспечения,
но для, например,
браузерного
антидетекта нет, увы,
она не подойдет.
Увы, но опять же, смотрите,
информация просто устаревшая.
Раньше процедура
генерализации это был,
скажем так, скрытый такой
козырь, который можно было использовать
вообще без каких-либо проблем. Практически
везде. Но на текущий момент, увы, она
по моему мнению, ну лично
по-моему, бесполезна.
Третий вопрос.
Где искать и как таких
технарей, как ты, в сети? Авито,
еще какие-то доски объявлений, сайты
с резюме для поиска работ?
Какую специальность они должны иметь и опыт?
По каким критериям искать их?
Кирилл, если бы я знал ответ на этот
вопрос, у меня бы не было проблем
с наполнением штата саппортов.
Увы, как показывает
практика, на протяжении
стольких лет
найти человека,
который
был бы
технически подкован,
при этом являлся не
интровертом и
был всесторонне
развитым, ну
очень сложно. Это
я не знаю, какой это шанс.
Один на миллион,
может быть так. Поэтому, к сожалению,
на этот вопрос я ответить не могу.
Вопрос номер
четыре. На прошлом вебинаре ты говорил про
легкость определения антифрауд
в систему конкретного сайта. Можно ли
после определения понять,
на что он смотрит, как работает,
что ему важно, или это только тесты?
Можно проверить только
лишь фронт-энд, то есть то,
как веб-ресурс взаимодействует с вашим
браузером. Но бэк-энд,
то логика, как эти параметры
обрабатываются, к сожалению,
доступна только лишь
создателям, либо владельцам
этой конкретной антифрауд-системы. Мы
можем узнать это только путем полевых
тестов.
Пятый вопрос. Ты говорил про анонимную
работу на System76,
про дисковое шифрование с правдоподобным
отрицанием. Для чего это нужно?
Для обхода антифрауд-системы или нет?
Или что имелось в виду?
Методика правдоподобного отрицания
необходима для
сохранения почек, в первую очередь.
Объясню.
Представьте себе, что есть
какой-то человек,
который не совсем согласен
с правовой
системой в какой-то стране.
Этот человек ведет
деятельность со своего ноутбука.
В определенный момент
этого человека
задерживают
сотрудники правоохранительных
органов. После чего
изымают его ноутбук,
который описывают и
затем отправляют,
который отправляется на
экспертизу. Экспертиза
заключает при осмотре,
что, например,
физических модификаций не
обнаружено, в программной
установлен, например,
пароль. Ну, не пароль Windows,
конечно же, а пароль,
используется предположительно одна из систем
шифрования таких-то, таких-то.
Затем этот протокол осмотра
через некоторое время
попадает следователю.
Следователь не согласен
с этим и
совершает процессуальные
действия следующего характера.
Он путем
психофизического воздействия
на подозреваемого
может на задержанного
в данном случае может,
скажем так, вынудить
его к компрометации
данного пароля.
Поскольку никто не будет
тратить ресурсы для того, чтобы
взламывать данный пароль с помощью
каких-либо технических
средств, если вы
находитесь в стране третьего мира.
Соответственно,
подозреваемый, а точнее задержанный
после примененных
к нему не совсем
процессуальных, но тем не менее
психофизических мер воздействия
будет согласен сообщить
данный пароль. После чего
данный пароль
указывается в уголовном деле
и отправляется, опять же,
к экспертам.
За что следователь получает себе
дополнительную, условно говоря,
награду в лице,
скажем так,
преференции от начальства.
После чего
эксперт проводит
осмотр данного
программного
данного ноутбука на предмет
нахождения тех или иных
скажем так
доказательств для
доказательной базы.
И вот здесь кроется самая главная
фишка,
что эксперт скажет, что там нету
ни хрена. Почему
такое происходит? Дело в том,
что методика правдоподобного отрицания
позволяет использовать
одну область,
но зашифрованную,
двумя разными,
ну, не то чтобы двумя разными методами,
а разделенную на два разных хранилища.
Внешнее и внутреннее.
Подозреваемый,
для того, чтобы избежать
психофизических мер воздействия
и идти на помощь следствию,
что может хорошо быть принято
на вынесении приговора,
но плохо будет принято
в тюремном мире,
он, соответственно, сообщает пароль
от ноутбука,
в котором ни хрена, фактически,
нету. Почему? Потому что
вся информация скрыта под другим паролем.
То есть, иными словами,
такой небольшой принцип матрешки.
И начиная с 98-го года,
когда этот метод правдоподобного отрицания
был впервые опубликован,
еще мне лично неизвестны методики,
с помощью которых этот метод
можно идентифицировать.
Вот, так что
вот как работает правдоподобное отрицание.
Дальше,
вопрос номер шесть. Из последних вебинаров
также, что значит
Linux лучше OS, как
база для анонимной работы?
Это про обход AF-систем или для чего?
Нет. Не путайте теплое
с мягким. Обход антифрод-систем
к анонимности имеет очень
малое отношение, поскольку
в анонимности нам необходимо,
несмотря на то, что скрыть
свои идентификаторы, но, тем не менее,
мы можем использовать кое-какие,
скажем так, хитрости,
которые позволят нам...
Ну вот, нам не нужно показывать геолокацию.
Не нужно.
Нам не нужно соблюдать резидентский IP.
Нам не нужно соблюдать WebRTC IP.
И так далее. Понимаете?
То есть те нормы, которые обязательны
для прохождения антифрод-системы, абсолютно
не обязательны для анонимности.
Linux,
то, что лучшая система
в плане гибкости настройки, да.
Потому что, конечно же, если сейчас
мы говорим о, например, операционной
системе Windows 11 в качестве
базы, ну это уже
очень сложно, скажем так, что-то сделать
более-менее внятно.
Windows Server, кстати, можно сделать
очень хорошо.
Дальше, седьмой вопрос.
Процессор T1, T2
в Mac'е для чего? Ты говорил
классная штука. Анонимность или обход антифрод-системы?
И для того, и для того я ответил
в контексте
ответа на
про Apple Silicon
и ноутбуки
до семнадцатого года.
Дальше, следующий вопрос
от пользователя Rocky7. А правда,
что в Мариарте было расследование
группы Госсера? Ваши путешествия
совпадают со съемками роликов
в Мариарте и ваша фигура тоже.
Извините, Рокки,
я не имею никакого отношения
к данному проекту
и, если честно,
блять, там какую-то херню
несут, мне как-то попадалось одно видео.
Ну, блять.
Ну, для, скажем так,
для обывателя это
интересно. А по факту,
блять, ну это пиздец.
Увы, куда
мир катится.
Дальше, следующий вопрос, вопрос от пользователя
Кирилл.
Чем отличается анонимность от обхода
антифрод систем?
Я же вам вот только что буквально
ответил, что в анонимности мы можем пожертвовать
тем, чем нельзя жертвовать в
антифрод системах. То есть мы можем
не заявлять свой IPv6
адрес, мы можем отключить UDP протокол,
мы можем не показывать
геолокацию, мы можем много-много
всего сделать, чтобы быть
более-менее схожим с остальной толпой,
но, тем не менее, не показывать
лишнего.
Девятый вопрос. На каких сайтах
смотреть, базово поменялись ли
параметры, все ли хорошо? Есть браузер
ликс, браузер скан, пиксель скан и т.д.
Говно, по твоему мнению.
И зачем они нужны, если они говно?
Окей, хорошо, давайте вот
возьмем мы пиксель скан,
раз у нас последние вот списки.
Давайте включим
логику сейчас. Если
мы заходим на пиксель скан,
и параллельно открываем вкладку
в хроме
WebRTC internals,
то мы видим подключение
WebRTC. Все классно, все супер,
никаких проблем нет в этом.
Но мы видим подключение
к серверам Threadmatrix,
про которые я уже множество раз
говорил. И
если мы заходим на Threadmatrix,
читаем их правила,
то у них для заключения
договора обязательно
необходимо раскрывать контрагенты.
Иными словами,
вы не можете заключить договор на
один сайт, а
использовать Threadmatrix на другом сайте.
Понимаете, к чему я говорю?
А соответственно,
Threadmatrix знает
о том, что
их антифрод система используется
на чекере пиксель скан.
Нужно ли проводить
логическую параллель дальше или
не нужно?
Как думаете? Ну это уже вам
решать. А где чекать?
Ну, во-первых, если вам так хочется чекать,
я не знаю. Вот, например,
до недавнего,
ну я не знаю, сколько лет может быть там,
хер его знает, сколько я уже
не пользуюсь никакими фактически чекерами,
кроме самописных. Самый простой
вариант. Хотите проверить,
ну я уже выкладывал множество
чекеров
в своих вебинарах,
в группах. То есть вы можете просто открыть
этот веб-ресурс на своем же локальном компьютере
и проверить самостоятельно себя.
При этом он ваш персональный
чекер, он никуда не стучит с вероятностью
100%. Абсолютно
открытый, никаких проблем с ним нет.
Плюс ко всему, ну опять же,
нейросети, они вам сделают любой
чекер за несколько минут.
И не нужно себя задрачивать,
думая о том, легитимный
тот или иной чекер или нет.
Зачем они нужны, вот эти те же
самые пиксель сканы? Ну,
Honeypot есть замечательный. Почему?
Ну вот я вам рассказал, какие
реальные цели
здесь можно говорить абсолютно по-разному.
Увы, мы
кроме самих создателей
данного чекера, никто реальных целей не знает.
Но то, что антифрод-система,
которую они используют, является топовой
в мире, это факт. То, что этой
антифрод-системе обязательно нужно
знать, к какому ресурсу она подключается,
это факт. То, что они знают об этом,
это факт. И такая антифрод-система
сидит и думает, э-э-эй, блять,
почему бы, блять, шума не натворить,
да, суеты какой-нибудь.
Выкинем все свои данные в паблик, блять.
Пусть люди, сука, чекают, да?
Ну, блять, ну,
ну как, ну это не
влазит в голову, блять.
Ой, десятый вопрос.
Извините за эмоции.
Десятый вопрос. Есть ли сайты, позволяющие определить
фродскор каждого профиля достоверный?
Нету. Одиннадцатый.
Как палят и палят ли инкогнито режимы
в браузере Safari, если регать с него БК,
например? Браузер сам
сообщает, что используется
режим инкогнито.
По поводу, там же
одно железо, одно и то же у айфонов, одинаковых
моделей куки не сохраняется, и вроде политика
конфиденциальность у Apple такая, что там нельзя.
Ну, если вы так думаете, то вы
сейчас открыли ящик Pandora,
и вы решили все проблемы
антидетектов. Оказывается, нужно просто
на Apple устройство включить
режим инкогнито. Ну, проверьте.
Должно же заработать. Вы
скажете потом на следующем вебинаре результат.
Двенадцатый. Что будет,
если зайти на Fingerprint.com? Дальше не хочу
читать даже.
Как понять, какую информацию тебе
дать? Ладно, нехорошо так все-таки,
извините.
Что будет, если зайти на Fingerprint.com?
Куда он данные сливает? В бока? Что делать
после захода, если так случилось?
Смотрите.
Fingerprint.com сам
является антифрод-системой.
Ему не нужно никуда данные сливать.
Благодаря их архитектуре
работы, веб-ресурсы,
на которые будут затем
переходить реальные пользователи, либо же вы
перейдете, если они
входят в орбиту Fingerprint.com,
они будут видеть, что вы уже посещали
их чекер. Они будут видеть ваши
данные с IP, блять,
и прочие данные людей, которые непонятно
зачем. Что, блять,
вы там пытаетесь на этих чекерах
найти? Скажите, может, я там что-нибудь
тоже поищу, блять? Может, там денег
найду, блять? Может, что я там, смысл жизни,
блять, обрету? Ёбаный
рот, блять, уже, ну, пиздец, ну,
честное слово, ну, хватит уже, ну, блять,
включайте критическое мышление, ебучий
случай, блять.
Как понять, какую информацию тебе запрашивают,
приложение, сайт? Провести анализ.
Следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя
5 глаз. Как бесплатно тестировать
геолокацию по GSM? Никаким
образом вы не сможете тестировать геолокацию
по GSM. Это видна, эта
информация видна оператору, либо
же она видна через
стек SS7 путем
выполнения VLR
запроса. Visitor Location
Registry запрос.
Но VLR запросы поддерживаются
не во всех сетях
не во всех сотовых операторах.
Но, в принципе, можно найти сервисы,
предыдущий сервис, который
выполнял VLR запросы,
называется TextCloud.
По Wi-Fi сетям
через базу Google вы можете воспользоваться,
если на телефоне, то я отвечал
вашему коллеге
написать приложение для
Android. Если для компьютера, вы можете
скачать приложение
Spy Wi-Fi бесплатно с сайта
DetectExpert.
Блестингс
3 восьмерки. Love you, Дмитрий. Love you,
Blessings888.
Дальше.
Виктор Дудко.
Что с людьми, которые
попали во второй тур на
конкурс саппорта? Я сегодня уже
сообщал об этом. Вы получите задание
завтра в личку от
меня. Дальше.
Следующий вопрос. Вопрос так.
Flood, Flood, Flood, Flood, Flood, Flood.
Flood.
Дэн Данилко. Здравствуйте. Что
скажете по поводу использования
Starlink, анонимности и конфиденциальности?
Дэн Данилко. Скажу
так, что нет там ни анонимности,
ни конфиденциальности.
Если мы рассматриваем спутниковый
интернет, то есть
только одно устройство.
И вот оно написано в чате.
Только это устройство может вам обеспечить
определенный уровень анонимности.
Идем дальше.
Следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя Arizona.
Дмитрий, подскажите, пожалуйста,
какая антифрод-система используется в Amazon
Нидерланды? На чем она основана?
В Amazon Нидерланды,
как и во всем остальном Амазоне,
используется система Amazon
Fraud Detector, их собственная,
которая имеет коннекты
к ReCAPTCHA 3
и к MaxMind.
Спасибо большое.
Большое спасибо за ваши вебинары.
Очень круто. Служу за вами еще с
2021 года.
Супер, 4 года, это уже отличный результат.
Уже даже 5, фактически.
Я рад, что мои вебинары
вас радуют.
Следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя Arizona.
Дмитрий, есть ли положительный фидбэк,
что ваша подмена камеры значительно лучше,
чем прошитые Root-устройства Android
с прошивкой, например, Verifuse?
Хочу оставить приятный отзыв.
Продолжайте в том же духе.
Вас приятно слушать, вы мотивируете.
Верифуса я, к сожалению,
не знаком с данными устройствами,
чем они интересны.
Но если это,
условно говоря, мультимодельная
прошивка, то у меня к ней есть вопросы.
Я сегодня не единожды
говорил по поводу Android.
К сожалению, повторюсь, не знаком
с системой Verifuse.
А чем лучше мое или нет,
я просто реализовал камеру.
Пока что эта камера работает только
в формате фото.
Видео еще не докрутил к ней.
Желание сделать есть все,
но, к сожалению, оно ограничивается тем,
что большинство технологий,
которые я применяю в антидетекте,
не было изобретено никем до меня.
И приходится,
не получается даже своровать чего-то.
Приходится все писать с нуля.
Дальше вопрос от пользователя Arizona.
Дмитрий, подскажите, пожалуйста,
когда выйдет новый видеогайд
по настройке антика?
Я думаю, что новый видеогайд
и будет этот видеогайд финальным
по пятой части антидетекта,
выйдет в середине февраля,
поскольку планируется большое
обновление для антика.
Ну и плюс ко всему необходимо показать,
как запускается
тот же самый Android и Chrome OS.
Так что не раньше, чем
обновление под Android.
Второй вопрос.
Когда планируется выпуск антика
на шестой версии?
Думаю, что это не раньше, чем
май месяц текущего года,
поскольку очень много
фиксов мы ждем
непосредственно от самой компании Oracle.
А они не очень быстрые
в этом плане. И то, что они хотели
реализовать, например, в ноябре
месяце прошлого года,
они реализовали только сейчас
в обновлении, которое вышло вчера.
Так что, увы,
здесь есть определенная зависимость,
потому что найти
разработчиков, которые разбираются
в устройствах, в драйверах
и в виртуализации,
ну, это разработчики на вес золота.
Кстати, если здесь есть
такие разработчики,
обязательно напишите мне в личку.
OldCookieBot, как я понимаю,
уже не активная технология.
Ваш проект великолепен.
Пожалуйста, продолжайте, не останавливайтесь.
OldCookieBot, я сообщал, что пока он не актуальный.
Проект будет продолжаться
и останавливаться не будет.
Он сколько уже существует?
С 2017 года?
Девять лет.
Отлично.
Дальше.
Пользователь Аризона.
Дмитрий, вы запускаете сегодня ночью
свой новый авторский курс.
Расскажите, пожалуйста, подробнее,
что будет на курсе?
Будет ли создана отдельная телеграм-группа,
где вы будете делиться инсайдами?
Ваши подписчики вас очень любят.
Правда, может, не так сильно, как в Нидерландах,
но все равно искренне.
Не знаю, при чем тут Нидерланды.
Спасибо на добром слове.
Если честно, буду откровенен,
я ввиду огромнейшей загрузки с антиком
давно не заходил
в группу
FraudLab.
Нужно выложить обновление,
но бляха-муха мне на все не хватает.
Поэтому очень постараюсь сейчас
закончить с типом номер 9
и буквально в течение пары дней
вернуться в группу
и ответить на все текущие вопросы
и порадовать новым контентом,
который уже записан,
осталось его только лишь чуть-чуть смонтировать.
Так что отдельная группа такая уже есть.
А курс есть,
ссылка на сайте DetectExpert.
Так,
следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя Данте Олегьери.
Приветствую, дорогой Виктор и дорогие друзья.
Приветствую, Давид.
Дима, у тебя хоть капля совести имеется,
когда собираешься на сборку делать?
Ты можешь зайти на сайт DetectExpert
и скачать ее
и, соответственно, работать с ней.
Хватит друзей обижать.
Да еще очень подло
на основе Linux-коста антик не делать.
И не собираюсь делать
на основе Linux-коста антик.
Вот.
Расскажу тебе лучше
про TPM.
Дальше.
Следующий вопрос.
Flute пропускаем.
Пользователь Arizona.
Это к вам относится.
Пользователь MMDems.
Привет.
Привет, MMDems.
Первое. Влияние скорости моего интернета
в антифрод-системах.
Какая должна быть минимальная?
Я это встречал нигде.
Вообще.
Есть только лишь определение,
что используются прокси
на основе скорости.
Но это я встречал только
в антифрод-системе Xeon.
Больше нигде не встречал.
Так что не могу сказать.
Может быть, на бэкэнде логика
присутствует в самописных системах.
Но в паблик-системах я не встречал.
Хотя, если честно, вру.
Если честно, вру.
Я, честно говоря, сейчас вам не припомню.
Дальше.
Перенос антика на bare-metal в USU.
Какие нюансы со стороны DetectExpert?
Никаких.
Нюанс только один.
У вас все будет работать намного лучше.
Главное, не забывайте о том,
что RDP-протокол
отключает 3D-ускорение.
Поэтому лучше
либо работать через
альтернативные источники
удаленного администрирования,
либо же запустить виртуальную машину,
а затем подключиться через
радмин.
Сделать это можно благодаря
API
без каких-либо проблем.
Дальше.
Моя проблема —
маленькая пропускная способность.
Под прокси еще меньше.
Ровень 4G до 50 Мбит в секунду.
А средняя в крупном городе США — 3000.
Разница в разы.
Уверен, что текущая лекция была крутая,
как и предыдущие. Всех благ.
Когда вы перенесете себя в США,
вы лишитесь этой проблемы.
И для удаленного подключения
вам вашей скорости
хватит вполне.
Главное, чтобы проксик выдержал.
Так.
Glitter Dev.
Вектор, у меня вопрос про памперы.
Будут еще, кроме Akamai?
Пока не планируется.
По факту можно было бы сделать
очень много всего, но
есть задачи более приоритетные.
Так, следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя.
Норм.
Есть ли какие-то гайды или способы,
как сейчас проходит тег New York Customer
проверки на сервисах,
где требуют именно селфи-видео?
Шановные нормы.
Это можно сделать очень легко.
Но вам для этого
нужна видеокарта
Nvidia 5090
и
установленная система
WAN 2.2.
С этой системой
вы сможете
полностью
симулировать
любую личность,
даже для сервисов
New York Customer.
У вас останется только одна проблема.
Проблема с кольоровой верификацией.
Когда вам будут
благодаря вашему
монитору, например,
демонстрировать
разные цвета для того, чтобы
увидеть их
изображение на вашем
лице.
Это может быть проблемой.
Так что
используйте другие.
Другого способа
не имею.
Дальше. Следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя.
Young.
Вы часто показываете, как устроены антифрауд-системы.
Почему классические антидетект-браузеры
дают ложное чувство безопасности?
Если представить, что у нас есть лекарство,
что у нас есть легальный белый проект
с высокой чувствительностью к рискам,
финтех, страхование, медицина.
Какие 3-5 принципов вы считаете минимально
достаточными для архитектуры анонимности
и операционной
безопасности команды,
чтобы снизить вероятность
деанонимизации ключевых людей,
анонимизировать утечки?
Я не могу
вам ответить на ваш вопрос.
Объясню почему.
В вашем уравнении слишком много
информации.
Поэтому я бы советовал,
как первый принцип,
принцип №1,
как второй принцип,
принцип №2,
а как третий принцип,
принцип №3.
Вот примерно такой ответ
по вашему вопросу.
Если хотите, можете обратиться ко мне
на личную консультацию,
где я максимально постараюсь помочь
в решении вашего вопроса.
Какие лучше DeepFake Tools,
чем DeepLiveCam,
которые присутствуют на DetectExpert
и на GitHub?
Я вам уже
рассказал.
Это 1.2.1
Первая буква W.
Следующий вопрос.
Есть ли какая-то интересная информация
о liveness
во время проверки селфи-видео
для KnowYourCustomer?
Это не моя тема.
KnowYourCustomer
это очень
вразливая тема.
Я не очень хочу
в паблике о ней
рассказать.
Следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя Miazar.
Здравствуйте, Дмитрий.
Здравствуйте, Miazar.
Каким типом подключения, каким софтом,
кроме OpenVPN,
вы бы посоветовали пользоваться
внутри виртуальной машины?
Я бы внутри виртуальной машины
не советовал пользоваться OpenVPN
вообще.
А вот каким типом подключения
используете виртуальные роутеры?
Это самый классный вариант.
Вот сегодня буквально люди говорили
о роутерах, таких как, например,
JetLine.
Отличный продукт.
Я бы упомянул сейчас еще GeoBox,
безусловно.
Но GeoBox это физическое устройство.
То есть это малинка
и может быть не всем удобно.
Например, людям неудобен
виртуальный роутер, который нужно
запускать в виртуальной машине.
Им проще работать с физическим устройством.
Поэтому разные методики.
Просто используйте то, что вам нравится.
Вопрос от пользователя Vic.
Здравствуйте.
Подскажите, какая система
для обхода антифрода лучше?
Windows 10 или Windows 11?
Здравствуйте, Vic.
Windows 11.
Следующий вопрос.
Хочу завести DADDY к Windows 11
и подключиться к нему через свой
защищенный канал связи, чтобы быть анонимнее.
Какие есть хорошие варианты
для пределов
дома, через
дома города и через
интернет?
Какие есть
хорошие варианты для...
Что думать, значит, если...
Увы, к сожалению, я не могу
поменять вопрос.
То, что вы хотите завести DADDY, я понял.
Подключаться к нему через свой защищенный канал связи, я понял.
Окей.
Но при чем здесь
пределы города, дома,
я, увы, к сожалению,
не понимаю.
КВМ здесь при чем? Это средство
виртуализации.
Информации об этом в курсе по анонимности
точно нет.
Увы, я не понял вопроса, извините.
Волк,
как лучше всего зайти
ИБ с нуля официально
и стоит ли этим заниматься?
Стоит ли быть
банкиром? Стоит ли быть
врачом? Стоит ли
быть боксером?
Стоит ли быть космонавтом?
Ну, каждый решает сам за себя.
Для меня, например, это
не...
Это не работа. Это
моя жизнь. И
несмотря на то, что, скажем
так,
жизнь можно
по-разному монетизировать. Я вам
так скажу. Поэтому
множество технарей знаю, которые
еле сводят концы с концами, притом
являясь блестящими технарями.
Но они просто не хотят
даже работать.
Не знаю, сложная
материя, смысл жизни.
Как лучше всего зайти?
Зайти необходимо
с пониманием основ
того хотя бы, как устроен компьютер.
Поэтому найдите книжки
по...
датированные началом
2000-х об устройстве компьютера.
Вот хотя бы
с этого необходимо начать. Потому что
иначе...
Да, понятно, что для того, чтобы строить дом,
не важно знать из чего, как
изготавливаются кирпичи или как изготавливается
цемент. Но
общие принципы понимания
вам однозначно
не повредят.
Дальше. Следующим
вопросом
вопрос от пользователя Вик.
Почему при установке антидетектора в контекстном меню
появляется запустить как вектор
Т13? У меня больше нет
функции запустить как администратор.
Потому что, Вик, у вас больше нет
администратора. У вас на компьютере теперь
вектор Т13. А вы думали,
где я свои прокси беру? Это ж
ботнет. Ботнет детект эксперт.
Зайдите в реестр
и измените себе, как хотите.
Хоть запустите от молодцы дома.
Блин.
Знаете,
ладно.
А как протестировать андроид
на симуляторы и эмуляторы?
С помощью антисимуляторного
и антиэмуляторного программного
обеспечения.
Здравствуйте.
А,
пользователи. А, здравствуйте. Спасибо
за вашу работу. И вам спасибо за то, что
пришли на мой вебинар. Подскажите, когда
вы сможете дать доступ к киберкрайм? С ноября
месяца жду открытия доступа. Условия
приобретения персональной версии выполнены.
А почему вы не написали
саппортом? Давайте разберемся. Напишите
мне в личку, и мы с вами этот вопрос
решим. Но не раньше, чем в понедельник.
Я предупреждаю сразу. Я поставлю
вас... Я запрошу
у саппорта ваши данные. Наверное, проще так будет.
Дальше.
Следующий вопрос.
Вопрос от пользователя Нар. Привет, Вектор.
Привет, Нар. В чем
преимущество Chrome OS перед
Windows в плане
анонимности? Никакого преимущества
нет. Полная херня в плане анонимности.
Учитывая низкую популярность
системы, есть риск привлечь лишнее внимание.
Безусловно. Тот же банкинг
или крупные транзакции на Chrome OS
это выглядит нетипично, так как
основная аудитория системы это студенты.
Не будет ли это выглядеть подозрительно для систем
мониторинга? Путайте теплое
с мягким. Анонимность и
антифрод системы это разные
вещи. Для антифрод систем
Chrome OS залетает великолепно.
Для анонимности не пригодено слово
совсем.
Дальше. Вопрос от пользователя
NAR. Имеет Android
от вектора будет иметь подмена
окружающих Wi-Fi точек и геолокацию?
На текущий момент
геолокация реализована, Wi-Fi точки
не реализованы.
Так.
Давайте, наверное, сейчас еще буквально
пара вопросов и
мы будем заканчивать
наш текущий вебинар, потому что
мы уже приближаемся к трехчасовому таймингу.
Так же, как и на прошлом вебинаре.
Итак, следующий вопрос
пользователя NAR.
Почему на сайте Virtual Card Type
Universal только США?
Когда будут европейские универсалы?
Не знаю, пока
вводить не планировал.
На текущий момент мы уже
имеем оборот, ну, сейчас
январь месяц, оборот немного упал.
Но, в принципе, в прошлом году,
к декабрю месяцу, мы уже дошли
до 250 000 долларов оборота
в сутки. И пока что
хотим, как минимум, этот оборот
сохранить для того, чтобы
не попасть
в какой-нибудь просаг. Поэтому
пока работаем с, условно говоря,
железобетонным фундаментом.
И расширять мы, безусловно,
планируем, но четко я вам
не могу сказать, когда.
Вопрос от пользователя Gold.
Будет ли подмена геолокации
в Android
антидетекте? Будет,
но GPS работает уже,
а вот Wi-Fi еще не реализован.
Ну, я думаю, что,
в принципе, на текущих наработках под
Windows это не будет являться
большой проблемой.
И еще один
вопрос от пользователя Nar.
На сайте в разделе Education у меня был
этичный хакинг, но уроки
не открываются. Пишет Error22061.
Что-то
залито, то, что залито
на Vimeo работает с саппортом,
не смогли решить проблему. Можете
пофиксить. Я не знаю
такой ошибки. Я запрошу
саппортов и обязательно дам
обратную связь на следующем вебинаре,
либо же оно просто у вас все
работает. Дорогие друзья, наверное,
на этом все, потому что вопросов
меньше не становится. Да,
их было 167, осталось 135.
Не знаю, на сколько я ответил,
но в этот час я попытался вложиться
максимально. Большое спасибо
за ваше внимание. Я надеюсь, что вам понравилось
мое выступление.
Буду рад, если вы опубликуете
свой отзыв либо на YouTube, либо в наших
Telegram-группах. Это будет
мотивировать меня сделать следующий вебинар
12-го числа просто легендарным.
Спасибо большое.
Буду радовать вас хорошим контентом.
Желаю всем приятного субботнего вечера.
Всего доброго.
С вами был Vector T13.